[Musique]
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
moi je m'appelle jean luc mélenchon
et je suis candidat à l'élection de
présidentielle
voilà
comment vous faites pour tenir
toute cette pression depuis tant
d'années comment vous faites pour tenir
les attaques comment fais tu pour
encaisser comment comment
jean luc ign j'ai dû tiré le bon numéro
du code génétique j'ai aucun mérite donc
ça me donne une endurance physique
qui permet de corriger la trajectoire
qu'on ne sait pas la bonne quand on a
pris trop de coups mais sinon
d'abord dans le style campagne
présidentielle c'est la troisième donc
il ya des choses que on aborde avec plus
de tranquillité qu'à la première ou la
vois aucune idée de ce que ça pouvait
être de l'organiser j'avais organisé
toutes sortes de choses avant des
campagnes municipales cantonales
législatives et une présidentielle non
bon maintenant ça va je crois que j'ai
montré que j'avais quelques un petit
talent toucher de balle on peut faire
des campagnes de cette nature et puis
j'aime ça parce que je pense que les
campagnes c'est des moments pour des
gens comme moi qui sont des militants
politiques de toute la vie une campagne
électorale c'est un moment
extraordinaire tout le monde se mêle de
politique
tout on a des idées sur tout et puis
vous arrivez le temps principe mieux
équipée si vous avez travaillé avant
j'avais des réponses
là j'ai un programme donc
il en est à sa troisième campagne s'est
affinée c'est assez excitant si vous
voulez de développer de se confronter
aux autres
de
marquer des points du foie en marque et
pour un intellectuel
c'est apaisant marqué un point parce que
vous vérifiez qu'un calcul
intellectuelle peut se traduire dans la
réalité de la vie par un rapport de
force
quand je parle de rapports de force à un
rapport de force sur la scène politique
ça se voit pas c'est on déploie pas des
soldats
donc
c'est un moment très fort de démocratie
puis je suis un religieux de ça moi je
n'hésite pas à le dire j'ai la
république pour moi c'est quelque chose
de c'est une idée c'est une pratique
donc oui c'est des moments très exalté
après prendre des coups je vous rassure
un personnes s'y habitue je veux pas
dire je me suis fait
l'acide pas sous l'armure
et puis bah on apprend à se réparer à le
surmonter mais encaisser les coups je
crois que même un boxeur aime pas ça
j'en connais pas enfin en tout cas je ne
connais pas assez peut-être d'en savoir
en avoir vu un qui a dit j'adore mon
prendre une enquête fasse ou c'est
délicieux en crochet au menton
ça n'existe pas donc moi non plus et
puis le temps passant
la vie mort a conduit dans une sorte de
boucle qui fait que j'ai commencé mon
engagement politique très jeune est dans
un état de grande révolte contre le
système dans lequel je vivais pour plein
de raisons qui tout était pas aussi
aussi extraordinaire rétrospectivement
que je pouvais le croire sur le moment
mais après avoir
fait tout un parcours
mon point de vue à mon âge et 70 en faux
je m'en convaincre
est presque aussi
radicalement en retrait
des valeurs du monde dans lequel je vis
que ça l'était à l'époque
peut-être davantage parce que là la
profondeur de champ de l'expérience
enseigne d'une manière beaucoup plus
forte les choses avec lesquelles on ne
peut pas faire de compromis parce que ça
ne sert à rien d'essayer d'en faire et
que on ne peut avoir que des rapports de
force alors tout ça c'était jusqu'à
4 5 ans il ya deux trois ans une
première bascule je comprends que le
changement climatique est en cours et
qu'il est irréversible et donc tout à
coup tout ce que je croyais tout ce que
je pensais est obligé de se re formulée
parce que les délais d'accomplissement
sont plus courts j'ai vécu toute une vie
remise en bon bah si c'est pas ce coup
là sera le suivant de toute façon on
finira par l'emporter et puis j'ai vu
des belles victoires j'ai vu 81 j'ai vu
des choses auxquelles on a cru être eu
vingt huit
maintenant je sais qu'il ya un délai de
temps qui fait que la civilisation
humaine est un point de bascule je veux
pas le
sol moment comme j'ai compris à quel
point ça lui est grave
peut-être que j'ai eu tendance à me dire
à voir le tableau d'une manière plus
catastrophistes que je le vois
maintenant serge me dit de toute façon
la nature n'a rien à fiche de nous elle
va se réorganiser
elle va trouver un nouveau point d
équilibre et peut-être que les êtres
humains se faufileront mais auparavant
il est très vraisemblable que
l'essentiel de ce qu'on connaît ne
fonctionnera plus n'aura plus lieu et
comme ça c'est produit grâce à plusieurs
auteurs on sait maintenant plusieurs
fois dans l'histoire et aucune raison de
penser qu'on va y échapper donc on peut
faire des choses mais je suis sans
illusion sur le fait que à la fin de ce
siècle
sournois retourner la situation soit bon
mais les arrières petits enfants feront
face à un monde qui n'aura strictement
rien à voir avec tout ce que j'aurais pu
connaître vivre est bon c'est la loi de
la bille après tout si tout d'un coup
josé un bond dans le passé
supposons deux cent mille ans et que je
tombais sur les premières petites bandes
errantes
d'êtres humains avec des petites
sociétés très organisée et très
solidaires pour se protéger beau et je
venais leur raconter ce qui est un
téléphone portable
bon
donc il faut voir ça dans la profondeur
de l'histoire comme elle est et donc là
on a une tâche à faire une
responsabilité qu'on peut prendre on
l'apprend l'assument et advienne que
pourra
prendre conscience des choses est ce que
ça vous a fait une petite dépression est
ce que c'est de la soul est l j
c'est-à-dire non d'abord reprendre
conscience ça me fait marrer j'ai souri
parce que
le hawk is comedy lé sourire s'éveiller
tu vois il ya une querelle autour de ce
mot qui me fait me marrer
parce que bon je pense que c'est le fait
d' ignorant qu'ils ne savent pas que ces
veillées s'émanciper c'est l'histoire
longue de la pensée qu'est-ce que j'ai
eu aussi qui m'a fait marrer mais bon
c'est bon c'est pas drôle ah pardon hein
mais la lutte contre l'intersexualité
c'est tellement ridicule c'est à peu
près comme si vous me disiez
je suis opposé à la loi de la
gravitation parce que ça fait tomber ben
oui peut-être bien c'est une loi de la
nature et l'intersexualité en politique
c'est de la sociologie s'il ya donc des
couches qui s'accumulent nos causes et
d'effets voilà enfin bon pardon c'était
pas votre question c'est mais quand vous
avez commencé par le mot éveillé c'est
pour ça que j'ai réagi vu ce qu'il va me
parler de ça ben non c'est pas ça dont
vous parlez non la conscience est pas
une souffrance
c'est peut être une secousse mais c'est
jamais douloureux
pour moi ça me met toujours un appétit
de savoir
et je trouve ça excitant
je lis beaucoup jeu des fois j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir trouvé une piste alors
je m'engage à fond je me disais je ne
suis pas élu à cette élection
présidentielle
j'aimerais m'inscrire en fac pour pour
que nous pouvons améliorer ma formation
et puis faire de l'anthropologie donc je
n'ai la prise de con science n'a
ne savait pas comment on s'est construit
un
mois j'ai fait un passage par albert
camus n'était pas qui était pas un
passage obligé pour quelqu'un comme moi
que tu as un matérialiste au sens
marxiste du terme ou philosophique du
terme le passage par camus était pas
obligatoire l'otan camus bon c'est pas
tout à fait la famille
de d'une certaine gauche mais enfin peu
importe et dans le mythe de sisyphe qui
m'a impressionné et marquer je crois a
dit j'ai retenu la leçon
vous savez si il fait condamner alors
leur chair ou jusqu'en bas puis quand il
y en a qui leur montrent et puis le truc
redescend il faut la remontée et camus
spécule réfléchi sur
il dit il faut imaginer sisyphe heureux
bon c'est une phrase mais moi c'est le
bonheur qui m'a interrogé en quoi
consistait alors lui dit tenir le rocher
et les bons
jeux je pense de même chaque fois qu'on
est devant une énorme difficulté
désespérante
j'en reviens à ça à la joie de de
trouver sa place et je crois que pour un
intellectuel comme c'est léon trotsky
qui disent hey c'est une phrase de léon
trotsky je crois qu'il m'a marqué qui
dit il n'ya pas de bonheur plus grand
que pour un intellectuel que de
comprendre ce qui se passe et il
trouvait sa place bon pour lui ça pas
été fameux comme résultat mais si on
prend l'enseignement il peut me servir
encore aujourd'hui
donc la conscience elle peut être
douloureuse elle peut être et peut être
sidéré sur certains sujets vous voyez et
on sort pas de cette sidération
par exemple le le génocide des juifs par
les nazis reste pour moi un objet de
sidération absolue comment
comment j'ai lu des choses sur le sujet
hannah arendt parle bien de la la
banalité du mal
dans le procès eichmann
comment des gens pu organiser et se
déresponsabiliser gers pas moi moi
j'organise est d'être un blu ray je sais
pas et cette force tranquille du mal qui
aboutit sur l'exécution méthodique de 6
millions de personnes
après ça a été d'autres massacres je
pense par exemple aux dictatures
argentines ils ont tué trente mille
personnes et la dictature a failli
d'ailleurs
elle a provoqué sans doute des éléments
de sa propre chute par le caractère
méthodique qui était cet assassinat et
toute une série de militaires 10ème nuit
militaire on veut bien combattre le
terrorisme et tout ça bien sûr mais mais
tuer des gens comme ça faut se rendre
compte de ce que ça veut dire tué trente
mille personnes ça veut dire les
ramasser les arrêter les numéroter vous
savez les bureaucrates ont besoin de ça
il faut qu'ils fassent des listes j'ai
connu quelqu'un quitte à peynier liste
contre son gré ma grand mère disait
toujours méfie te vois des gens qui
tiennent des listes
complètement tort mais j'ai connu une
femme qui tenait une liste comme ça
contre son gré un je voudrais pas que
mes propos là
la blesse si elle est toujours vivante
et le fait de l'avoir connu m'a aidé à
mieux comprendre comment les tyrans
pouvait organiser des meurtres de masse
avec une complicité énorme parce que tu
es 30000 personnes c'est une industrie
donc ma sidération dans le domaine elle
reste la même salle et j'ai toujours pas
compris
et j'habite c'est pas que j'amenais pas
mais je suis toujours aussi
glacé par sahin
et quelle que soit la situation quel que
soit le le régime politique
quand quelque chose se met en oeuvre
pied de cette nature
alors oui c'est lui les moments où on a
des doutes sur
ce que les êtres humains qui sont
capables de faire si bien que l'extrême
conscience vous mais toujours à la
limite de la misanthropie
c'est à dire de cet endroit où vous
dites mais
ils sont capables de ça à quoi bon
mais ça le fait pas parce que
sitôt que vous en avez conscience est en
queue comme
tout processus de savoir l'autre soir je
racontais ça aux gens ça les a fait rire
mais mon idée était jaboot irait dans un
prochain meeting je vais développer ma
pensée sur le sujet mais je disais vous
savez si vous savez rien
imaginer que le savoir et l'ignorance le
savoir c'est un point d'accord et a une
circonférence
si vous savez rien la circonférence est
tout petit donc vous savez pas vous
savez pas
mais plus vous en savez plus la
circonférence est grand mais plus vous
savez que vous savez pas
alors ça s'applique aux responsabilités
de la conscience mais c'est pareil pour
le sentiment moral de la liberté plus
vous savez à quel point
quelqu'un est capable de faire n'importe
quoi plus le prix de votre propre
liberté et de votre capacité à décider
et l'extraordinaire responsabilité que
ça vous confère tout d'un coup vous
surgit et et ça par contre c'est
merveilleux parce que c'est une prise de
conscience de soi de sa liberté de sa
responsabilité c'est très prometteur que
mythe un
prométhée dhia ben parce qu'elle est
puis mettez à oublier mais à tous les
animaux quelque chose puis au dernier
moment mais lui reste l'homme zut il
sait rien faire il sait pas courir vite
il n'y a pas de grippe il n'a pas de
grosses dents alors bon désespoir arrive
prométhéa l'a répété il paraît que ça
veut dire celui qui se rappellent pas ou
qui cas pas prévu et puis promettait
alors lui c'est le gac a prévu et alors
il dit bon ben il reste rien alors je
vous donne l'intelligence et
l'intelligence mais pas pour juste pour
dire vous allez vous débrouiller dans le
mythe à eddy passe comme ça vous allez
décider qui vous êtes et moi je suis
fondamentalement prométhéen et là la
naissance de l'humanisme en europe
c'est ça c'est d'abord ça on part de
sabon comme j'ai répété dix mille fois
je vais pas faire le pédant mais c'est
le livre de le pic de la mirandole qui
s'appelle de la dignité de l'homme et
post il peut ça c'est pourquoi
je crois que c'est mon école
philosophique et intellectuelles et le
jour où j'ai fini ma première brillante
élection présidentielle c'est à dire en
2017 j'ai terminé bon on a un peu
souffler je suis allé dans une maison à
marseille qui était bien isolé et la
première chose que j'ai fait c'est
essayer d'écrire un texte que j'ai écrit
pour faire le lien entre le concept
d'insoumission
au sens le plus large possible et
l'humanisme du départ et je continue à
travailler cette idée si vous voulez on
fait pas de politique
dans ma famille sens large sans
philosophie que ça existe pas et je ne
veux pas dire que mes adversaires n'en
fasse pas ce qu'ils assument je parle
pas des
quatre longs gants avec deux
publicitaires et puis quatre experts qui
sortent du bureau qu'il impressionne
avec des grands mots alors après il
couvrira comme ça mais c'est pas vrai
que je dis quand même des fois tout est
permis on arrive bien vous faire acheter
des choses qui vous servent à rien alors
donc peuvent y arriver à vous faire
voter pour des trucs qui vont se
retourner contre vous mais je veux pas
que mon propos laissant en tant qu' il
n'y aurait pas dans le camp d'en face ou
qui s'opposent parce qu'en face il ya
ceux à qui on sait l'adversaire absolue
1 c'est l'ennemi et puis l'adversaire
bon le temps passant disons que j'ai
mais pas sur le même plan quelqu'un de
droite est quelqu'un d'extrême droite je
vais pour moi cet appareil peut être que
plus jeune oui j'aurais dit oui c'est
tous les mêmes par dix et des trucs
comme ça
non c'est pas vrai il ya une droite
républicaine et y croire de cloud il
croit que
bon il donne une place à l'individu qui
est quasiment en opposition à la société
celle qui avait été le plus loin dans
cette concision du monde c'est madame
thatcher alors elle était plutôt la
branche libéral en france la droite
traditionnelle elle est plus
patrimoniale
plus ils ont le défaut la coincer ses
dires est abondant mais
bon ils sont méchants sans le savoir
pas toujours rien à qui le savent et
puis bon ils s'en foutent d'ailleurs
mais les libéraux c'est une autre
variété ans et
ils sont sévères c'est madame cette
chaire la reine elle disait et c'est
pour ça qu'elle est intéressante elle
dit un truc été rime lundi la société
n'existe pas
la cgt veut justement il ya que des
individus qui sont obligés d'être en
relation les uns avec les autres et si
ils optimisent la nature de leur
relation ça ira bien pour tout le monde
c'est incroyable dedans de brutalité
mais en même temps reconnaissons
d'intelligence parce que bon trublion du
monde qui est très cohérent je pense que
le président macron il est dans cette
vision du monde et que qu'il le sache ou
pas mais à mon avis il est assez cultivé
pour le savoir et en faire un une
manière d'être qui voulait on peut
passer expliquer les saillies qui fait
de la part d'un homme intelligent et
cultivé comment il trouve le moyen de
traiter les uns d'illettrés les autres
de rien mais à droite ne parlait pas
comme ça avant il sait qu'on est des
gens de peu le bon peu c'était déjà
quelque chose mais rien on prêt à
s'expliquer ce genre de sortie s'il n'y
a pas dans son esprit ça c'est à dire au
fond la société existe pas et vous est
entièrement responsable au sens littéral
du terme mais pas le mien moi je dis
vous êtes entièrement moralement
responsable de ce que vous faites lui
considère vous êtes responsable de votre
sort alors bon à la faute du chemin chez
acquis aux chômeurs et alors là où il
nous a fait le mou le maximum c'est et
la maladie c'est la faute à qui ou
malades gk vous vacciner si vous serez
pas malade donc vous nous casser les
pieds et puisque vous vous casser les
pieds je vais vous les cas c'est
également ils disent mais vous emmerder
c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais vu un
gars qui dirige en pays et qui a l'air
de découvrir que gouverner un pays c'est
pas gouverner des choses ont dû
peut-être que 67 68 millions mais ce
sont des français des gens avec un
certain niveau de culture pas trop
habitué à s'en laisser conter ils sont
disciplinaire parce que vous avez vu ce
qu'ils ont supporter le confinement le
massepain de la souys le match belmas
comme était le le médical le fp2 et
sortait en tracy niveau un papier pour
vous autoriser à sortir tout le monde a
accepté cet immense exercice de dressage
que ça a été moi j'ai trouvé les
français magnifique
nous sommes en guerre c'est complètement
fou de tenir un propos pareils ça n'a
pas de sens en fait pas la guerre à un
virus on a une crise sanitaire donc on
affronte une crise sanitaire donc il
faut des réponses scientifiques qu'est
ce que c'est de sa soeur qu'est ce qu'on
fait et puis des moyens bon alors les
moyens
en gros comme on augmente l'immunité des
personnes et de la société
cet accident oui j'ai fait parce qu'on
m'a dit d'abord parce que moi je fais
partie des gens qui au vaccin quoi je
m'excuse auprès de ceux qui peut être
n'y croient pas de manière virulente
mais moi je crois à la science alors
après je sais qu'il ya un doute sur son
efficacité je le connais puis là il est
évident le doute en ça marche pas et
qu'au micro que c'est normal c'est pas
un bouclier universel puis à l'heure est
à la vérité je vais vous dire je m'en
fout quoi au micron est une épidémie
différentes de covile 19 puisque le
barrage de commis 19 empêche pas au
micro-ondes bref on affronte une
situation triste sanitaires et donc il
faut des réponses adaptées à ce que
c'est si c'est la guerre bat fait la
guerre si c'est la crise sanitaire bas
fait la crise sanitaire mais on mélange
pas les deux et surtout pourquoi on
mélange pas les deux parce qu'on fauche
l'imaginaire des gens et nous autres
êtres humains
travaille qu'avec imaginaire tout notre
tête est une machine à produire des
explications
si vous voulez établir des différences
entre des gens qui ont des maladies des
handicaps mentaux et d'autres c'est
souvent la capacité à imaginer pour
expliquer et il ya des cerveaux qui ont
de la difficulté à imaginer donc quick
et coupe c'est à dire il ya un bruit
violent vous votre cerveau produit pas
un qu'est ce qui se passe comment je
vais réagir il produit s'est rien passé
et pouf dans la vie politique aussi on
va dire ça comme ça dans mon cerveau a
pas assez d'imagination pour se dire
tiens il s'est passé quelque chose
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir faire et
puis vous avez la ribambelle des
technocrates
bon car il pas à comprendre par exemple
pourquoi la population des antilles veut
pas se vacciner
il arrive alors comme ils n'arrivent pas
à trouver une explication 10 en avant l
entendre
je crois vous avez raison de dire ça
pour une pareille dans pas envie de
s'entendre dire pourquoi mais enfin le
résultat à la fin j'ai vu sur un plateau
de télé un type dire tranquillement que
c'était parce que les martiniquais
croyez au vaudou
vous en tombent des martiniquais les
premiers 10 mai pour qui nous prend quoi
en plus il est vraiment il est mal tombé
parce que si ces clips sur un plateau
j'ai oublié son nom mais ça m'a
tellement voix sur les plateaux montant
tour tout absolument tout et puis
personne les arrêtant le gars dit ce
qu'il veut le suivant hui alors
maintenant passer la parole à monsieur
machin qui dit n'importe quoi on passe
au suivant c'est bien là nous ou
pour l'ascenseur attendait faut pas
faire confiance lénine disait que les
imbéciles qui font confiance cgap pro
fait confiance à 7 vous êtes toujours
comme ça sur pas la défensive mais
comme un animal blessé qui s'attend à se
faire rebaisser
non je vais vous dire c'est plus simple
je suis mal entendants de naissance et
du club il paraît que vous aussi bon
alors vous connaissez le comment se
construit la psychologie d'un
malentendants si vous êtes matérialiste
sectaire vous ne voyez pas les gens vous
ne savez pas qui sont là donc la plupart
du temps la vie surgit pour vous et donc
vous passez votre temps votre cerveau
passe son temps à faut pas avoir peur
c'est pas grave
j'ai observé les gens qui on en est mal
et je me suis aperçu beaucoup et je me
suis aussi je faisais aussi passent
beaucoup de temps à bien regarder
pas où quelqu'un peut entraîner par
parce qu'on essaye de rester civile donc
distingue aussi les résistants aussi
regardent toujours qui peut entrer et
moi je m'assois jamais le dos à la porte
nous non plus
alors bon il faut raconter des histoires
je vous en propose une parce que sinon
ça fait ça fait un peu moche elle tombe
non mais non c'est pas qu'on a le temps
mais je vous la raconte vouloir les
vrais sujets mais non celle en direct on
est en direct alors oui c'est vrai qu'on
est en direct il paraît que j'ai c'est
james est mort comme ça a dit prendre
dans le bistrot et dias et du cjebs lui
a tiré dessus alors et pourquoi pas ce
que c'était que je sais bien voilà alors
si vous voyez que l'art de faire parler
de soi on se rendort marchande en son
pouvoir de nuisance
le plus grand cas qu'on est dans ce cas
moi je parle autant vous m'arrêtez pas
je passe d'une idée à l'autre vous
connaissez le plus grand cas de
l'histoire de type kia marchander un
buzz
le premier buzz de l'histoire sévère
extraterrestre aux etats unis c'est ça
non dans ce passé le simple que si les
morceaux de noël ce nom
le plus grand ballon c'est dans
l'antiquité grecque c'est un type qui a
foutu le feu au temple de thémis et fès
c'était une des merveilles du monde
libre où j'ai fait ça pour qu'on parle
de moi pour que dit il pour que la
notoriété retiennent non non et donc les
juges horrifié après l'avoir condamné à
mort décide que partout son nom serait
gravée au monde enlèverait alors disons
par solidarité avec sept merveilles du
monde incendie je vous dirai pas son nom
et vous irez les chercher mais ça m'a
amusé une fois de penser que
la première fois que cette histoire
m'est revenu à l'esprit je me suis dit
mais qu'est ce que je suis en train de
faire je répète le long d'un [__] qui
avait calculé son affaire pour faire du
buzz et quand même
25 siècles après à cause de moi on parle
de lui et qu'on cette culture ça de la
cancel culture ouais la cancel culture
en france a bien commencé on a foutu par
terre la bastille donc
ça veut rien dire ils ont inventé un nom
c'est normal que les gens changent et
statut de place tout tu toujours on fait
ça alors regardez quand y mettre la
statue de saddam hussein par terre
personne a été dire c'est de la cancel
culture dans tous les styles ont regardé
les statues de lénine de de staline
apparemment personne ne regarde
pas tout vous avez raison bon rien elle
est vraiment beaucoup donc il y en a
pour un moment les enlever tout et nous
aussi on a enlevé les révolutionnaires
de 89 si vous êtes passé à saint denis à
la cathédrale iso tout péter quoi
tout casser et puis ils se mangeaient
alors c'est assez banal quelqu'un m'a
dit mais vous trouvez normal d'enlever
la statue de colbert
moi perso je réfléchis avant avant de
crier
mais pourquoi des gens intelligents que
je connais veulent enlever la statue de
colbert parce qu'il a fait le le code
noir est alors le code noir c'est un
code pour resserer pourquoi pas suffi
d'une histoire qui prévoit les punitions
les conditions dans lesquelles les
esclaves sont traités alors l'onglet des
gens qui viennent qui disent c'est pas
faux qui disait en bus et l'époque
heureusement qu'il y avait un code parce
que comme ça c'est moins pire que de
laisser faire les gens n'importe quoi
mais ça c'est pas un argument contre
comprendre que ceux qui sont les
descendants
soient absolument horrifiés
chaque croix fois qu'ils croisent la
statue d'un type qu'à imaginer comment
tabac c'est parce qu'il en avait une
peur bleue des esclaves ils ont les
esclaves ont passé leur temps à se
révolter c'était pas des gentils dans un
coin ils sont pas laissés faire et donc
on peut comprendre que des gens soient
horrifié à l'idée qu'on met ton statut
un type qui a inventé des trucs pareils
et puis que les gens intelligents aussi
soit horrifié et 10 ne comprends pas
comment vous bon ok c'est l'histoire on
n'est pas obligé de célébrer ça
je vous donne un exemple parce que vous
pensez que c'est un peu loin mais je
peux revenir sur des choses plus
concrètes vous avez installé au caylar
et en cas de bonnes j'avais été élu
comme moi on vous met à votre bon dans
la gauche de l'hémicycle c'est à dire la
gauche du président une énorme statue
énorme
il marquait dessous saint-louis déjà ou
dit très haut c'est la république laïque
ici ou quoi pourquoi y laissant suis là
s'appelle louis 9 non
alors après les chercher dans les
bouquins maintenant même plus besoin il
ya le moteur de recherche wikipedia
si vous apprenez que ce saint louis
rendait la justice bah oui tu parles qui
rendait la justice le mec il a inventé
le plus la punition du blasphème par le
percement de la langue au fer rouge et
la rouelle pour les juifs
après à brûler quelques torah et décidé
de les [__] dehors les juifs ont été
expulsés 30 une fois c'était une
habitude dans l'ancien régime de
persécuté les juifs quand tu fais ça les
occupe est
bon il prenait une mesure comme ça on
dit sois bon on peut pas dire que ça a
marché fort d'ailleurs ni contre les
protestants toutes les répressions
religieuses n'ont jamais rien donné
d'autre que rien du tout et beaucoup de
souffrances pour rien les protestants ça
n'arrêtait pas pour un oui pour un non
alors que je te mets l'édit de nantes
après je te le retire
alors bon il mettait les dragons à
domicile pour convaincre les gens d'être
chrétien catholique peut imaginer le
mode de persuasion qu'un dragon pouvez
faire c'est louis xiv qui faisait là
montpellier à la statue blick à tort
d'aller tourner vers les cévennes lauga
et les rois de france il est persuadé
qu'il a reconquis pour les âmes dans les
cévennes alors voyez la politique parce
qu'on m'en sors pas c'est tout le passé
l'histoire le présent comment tout ça se
mêlent et à la fin chacun nous produit
un résultat est un type qui a essayé de
faire le malin il pensait qu'il était le
producteur officiel d'un résultat qui
n'existe pas il s'appelle monsieur
zemmour et avancer avec madame le pen
alors ils pensent que il incarne ce
qu'ils appellent la tradition dans leur
esprit
le futur étant passé toujours
recommencée mais c'est malheureux ignore
que
ça n'existe pas
ça n'existe pas ce qu'ils disent n'a
jamais existé la france n'a jamais été
comme ça
ou alors très peu de temps et dans
certains milieux la france n'était pas
unifiés par une religion il y en a
toujours eu trois les juifs les
protestants et catholiques
et puis maintenant il ya les musulmans
et puis aussi les bouddhistes et les
apostats
ça va de soi mais cela est mon rêve ita
le pas me lancer sur les apostasies si
si si si si marc fait pas le sujet c'est
un coup de patin dans la vie que l'apu
stasi en béton alors l'apostât est celui
qui a rogné dieu je vais juste faire un
tout petit bout d'histoire pour rigoler
ce qu'on est français et qu'on aime bien
par y
connaissez le boulevard saint-michel
sérieux de manif non vous savez quand
est-ce qu'elle a eu lieu la première
manif là
ça doit être je vais avoir trompé l'aja
l'art de la vidéo je sais plus si c'est
293 de notre ère
où un peu plus tard
enfin bref il ya eu à paris une fois un
empereur romain qui était pas encore
moins pour un sou il arrivait dorion il
avait de l'époque des empereurs et le
premier qui était le vrai boss foule
deuxième à paris on lui dise après avoir
massacré sa famille toi tu as là bas
paris c'est plus que landes
cia est il un arpenteur romain est
arrivé après la conquête et que je me
batte on s'appelle romain il ya quatre
petits plombs et puis tout droit la rue
saint-jacques cardo maximus dacquois
donc quand vous êtes au 174 il ya un
marchand de laquelle a dit cola c'est là
que le das émis et il y avait le bord
comme ça le panthéon ok là où il ya le
panthéon bas côtés jusqu'au jardin
après comment le boulevard saint-michel
donc à cette époque-là l'empereur que tu
es d'orgue' requis et mcdonald's mais
maintenant hélas est alors donc
l'empereur qui en orient 10 à celui qui
est à paris il y des étoiles a bien on a
besoin de toi à monter légion y en avait
deux alors ok j'arrive il faut pour être
c'est pas possible de dire non mais les
légionnaires ils en entendent parler
c'est des légionnaires gaulois donc ça
s'est très mal passé mais qu'ils ont
entendu dire ça dit quoi nous
légionnaires oui mais ici en orient pas
question aucune panne aux femmes ont ils
pas d'un gosse on reste ici et donc ils
ont fait une manif donc vous savez le
boulevard saint michel en bas vous avez
les termes je crois après vous passez
vous êtes sur l'île de la cité il ya le
palais de justice est là qui était le
lac et l empereur au numéro 2 qui a
failli mourir là dedans parce qu'elle a
eu à un feu qui a mal tourné dans sa
cheminée et
on fera elle vous parlera compte pas la
suite mais lui et finit par devenir
empereur l'autre en point se fâche mais
ils ont tout a dit de venir c'est
toujours pas là on le voit au milieu oui
j'arrive aux gaulois attendait ça va
s'arranger c'est un malentendu
coup de chance coup de pot absolue
l'oriental meurt donc l'an prochain
c'est lui
il monte sur son cheval ils courent
jusqu'à constantinople apprend un mois
et demi et quand ils arrivent au mieux
leur dire maintenant c'est moi qui
commande et il commence par dire le
catholicisme ça commence à bien faire le
christianisme à l'époque ça c'est pas
notre religion va rétablir l'ancienne
religion
problème personne se rappelle comment on
fait pour sacrifier un boeuf à jupiter
pour bon ça n'a pas marché du tout une
histoire ça a foiré mais par contre les
chrétiens n'étaient pas d'accord et donc
il est resté dans l'histoire comme
julien l'apostât
il a fini par se prendre une flèche dans
le dos une bataille à mon avis c'est les
tireurs étaient derrière mais il a fait
avoir un très beau texte s'appelle le
miso pogo et dit aux mecs d'antioche et
leur dire ah d'accord ah je me parfume
pas comme vous
adacore je ne me rase pas la barbe
l'empereur c'est moi alors vous allez me
recevoir et vous allez vous taire et
faire ce que je vous ai dit de faire
l'accord à quoi les gens naturellement
le répondu tout entier chérèque qui
s'était comme des gaulois va te faire
voir et donc il est mort peu de temps
après donc tout le monde on a été
débarrassée mais nous autres français le
seul empereurs romains qui ait jamais eu
chez nous c'est un apostat et la france
a un ancrage
toute son histoire si on comprend pas ça
on comprend pas la france l'une de ces
composants toute son histoire est une
histoire de révolte contre le
cléricalisme
les grandes hérésie populaire du moyen
âge sont toutes des hérésies populaire
et frappent les le clergé liés à la
noblesse
le premier acte dur d'un roi de france
pour affirmer son autorité
c'est philippe le bel contre le pape
boniface
après quand il met sur pied qu'ils
élisent henri iv qui met henri iv comme
roi c'est en protestant
il a fallu qu'il ya un parti royaliste
qui disent nous on s'en fout de la
religion le disait pas trop fort mais
c'est l'aîné de la branche aînée keroual
resteront pas le savoir la religion doit
pas servir de prétexte d'un type comme
montaigne et là dedans bon ça nous a
éloignés de la géopolitique mais ça va
nous permettre d'y arriver par la place
qu'occupe de nous les religions dans la
politique avant avant de rentrer dans le
côté géopolitique de la chose j'aimerais
qu'on revienne sur le réchauffement
climatique le dérèglement climatique
lalaye toutes les limites qui sont
dépassés comme la pollution chimique le
plastique la surconsommation
vous si vous arrivez à la place suprême
comment on va combattre ça on va
combattre ça auprès des industriels on
va combattre ça dans la tête des gens
c'était qu'on va leur expliquer on ne va
pas leur expliquer on va leur faire
comprendre on va pas leur faire contre
on va leur imposer on va pas leur
imposer
comment on fait quand on a une
population occidentale
qui est depuis 40 ans a été bercée par
du neuro martic marketing en leur
mettant profondément dans la tête que
avoir une grosse bagnole avoir des
machins des petits ppt abr on s'est
compris comment on fait
grâce l'industrie des pôles à la
publicité on la race pas qu'est ce qu'on
fait alors d'abord commençons par le
plus difficile dans la question c'est
les habitudes prises par et ses
habitudes c'est une culture une culture
c'est toujours globale ça vous l'avez
dans la peau dans la chair
tout le monde s'est habitué à des actes
absurdes
voit la première fois que j'ai entendu
parler d'un rasoir jetable
il faut vous souvenir que j'ai vu mon
grand père avec le coach ou
alors comme l'a vu baisser avec le temps
il se mettait alors la fenêtre avec le
gros miroir et puis il se rasait avec le
savon le couple ou quand il avait vu
arriver là mais les lames de rasoir
il trouvait que c'était quand même un
peu ballard nous quand on a vu les
rasoirs jetables arrivé au plastique
braille
pareil on s'est dit on est de fous là
alors pas jetable électrique
sauf que moi j'en ai et des fois ça
m'arrive de milliards il marche pas mal
ils marchent mieux que l'autre forcément
si changer plus souvent les dames
je marche seulement la figure mais bref
c'est pour vous dire on a pris comme ça
là je prends un exemple tout petit mais
du plastique y en a partout quand vous
remplacez les cuillères en plastique ou
des fourchettes en plastique par des
découverts en bois
demandez autour de vous les gens dit
ouais c'est bien ces responsables enfin
c'est pas pareil ils ont l'impression
que le plastique a pas de goût mais que
le bois 6
alors donc il faut pas raconter
d'histoires il faudra profondément
changer nos habitudes nos manières de
vivre elle voit pas la contrainte
changement nous commençons mais j'ai
voulu d'abord dire ça prouve pour
pouvoir d'abord dire écoutez ne vous
raconte pas d'histoires ce n'est pas ici
une affaires extérieures à vous je vous
mets une parenthèse le coup découvert
plastique c'est interdit maintenant sauf
que pour pour continuer à vendre ça ils
disent c'est réutilisables notamment en
a fini par voter que rien à faire c'est
me réutilisables n'y a rien du tout vous
le ferez pas l' empire vous allez voir
je vais venir sur la production c'est
quelque chose moi qui me qui
m'intéressent la production mais d'abord
on commence par la culture 1 parce que
si on lit ça on comprend pas ce qu'il a
à faire et on peut pas amener les gens à
la trique d'accord c'est essayer de
gouverner par la force ou la violence
vous n'y arriverez pas alors si ma peau
l'argent et tout ça ça veut dire que les
consciences doivent évoluer moi je pense
que les consciences au mur je vais vous
dire pourquoi tout le monde sait que ça
peut pas durer mais peut-être pas voir
pour peut-être cette fois-ci il pas
cette fois ci a encore un petit coup
pour la route bon alors le couvert il
est renouvelable il est réutilisable g15
avait bon donc on est tous des êtres
humains donc on est dans la pente
toujours
qu est ce qui coûte le moins d'efforts
même les révolutions ont dit qu'en
général les masses fond ce qui coûte le
moins d'efforts
donc c'est par l'amont qu'on va régler
la faire
et je ne crois pas à une politique
écologique qui repose à 100 % sur cette
faute parce que ça je reconnais les
libéraux derrière ça j'ai dit la maladie
c'est le malade qui est responsable le
chauffeur les responsables du chômage le
pauvre de la pauvreté non c'est pas vrai
on n'a pas le choix et il est énorme de
voir le nombre de fois où on vous dit
n'abusez pas de ceci ne fait pas cela
mais est incapable filet si tu veux pas
qu'on le fasse donc il faut changer et
partir aussi du défi accepté le défi
technique l'exemple du plastique bien
sûr qu'on ne peut pas continuer c'est
impossible
il ya bientôt or plus de plastique de
poissons dans la mer on le sait on
connaît la date
2050 si on continue à balancer nos
ordures comme ça dans la mer
méditerranée sera un ego n'y aura plus
de plastique queue de poisson d'ailleurs
on n'est pas tout à fait sûr que ça
perdure batteur endocriniens chez g râce
de poissons change de tout changement de
sexe chez les mérous qui aime son gérant
et ils sont tellement mal même si change
de sextos rebelles monségur les
observateurs comme est comme ça
réchauffe ça s'évapore plus vite et
comme ça s'évapore plus vite c'est plus
de flotte qui tombe d'un coup et plus de
neige à certains endroits nous dont il
ya du plastique et un pays où dans le
monde blanc il ya du plastique dans la
neige l'acier qui vient de la mer
méditerranée ou d'ailleurs m'enfin des
mères souvent jones exemple je crois que
c'est au groenland ils ont interdit aux
femmes de manger des poissons peut se
sont plaints de plastique
dans les pays nordiques
certains poissons qui concentrent trop
de mercure comme le saumon le thon sont
interdits aux femmes enceintes plus de
une ou trois fois par alors le poisson
en tirant passage puisqu'on est sur le
poisson
il s'est passé en 2013 un événement il
manque dans la civilisation humaine qui
a passé inaperçu on sait pas le jour de
nabil 1
non non cette année là on a mangé plus
de poissons d'élevage queue de poisson
pêché donc dans ce domaine
de poisson on est passé de la cueillette
ou de la chasse à l'élevage c'est ce qui
s'est passé au néolithique quand on a
découvert forme de découverte il paraît
qu'on a mis sur pied de manière
méthodique l'agriculture il semble
simple et antérieurement fin bon alors
on reste sur le les productions donc il
faut changer les productions et puis
partir du plus haut niveau d'exigence
pas au rabais vous avez l'habitude
d'avoir du plastique très bien est ce
qu'on peut faire du plastiques
biosourcés et qui se décomposent pas oui
on sait le faire avec des arrêts avaient
à ben ça coûte plus cher alors déjà il
ya la grande rupture psychologique
la grande rupture mentale philosophique
c'est à bâle moins cher moins cher
n'existe pas n'existe pas le bon marché
coûte très cher voilà parce que
c'est toujours payé par quelqu'un soit
la nature en sa cage en valeur sont
pauvres
soit avec du sang de pauvres ouais
et il ya un lien entre une violence
sociale finit toujours par une violence
dans la nature et ils ont dans la nature
finit toujours comme une violence
sociale
ça c'est très important à bien
comprendre parce que
si vous voulez ce que j'ai gardée de mon
passé des militants vous rendez compte
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure mon
âge donc moi j'ai commencé à militer il
existait un truc s'appelait l'union
soviétique et on pensait que dans
certaines familles politiques on pensait
que l'avenir du monde c'était le
communisme et que en union soviétique
ont mené les préparatifs d'accord bon
ouf et aïe kurion tout ça rien ne vient
pas une pierre sur l'autre rien plus
rien il amène ici qu'intervient lionel
jospin s'est rendu compte et qui dit on
pensait qu'on finirait par faire un
compromis mais de tout ça il ne reste
plus rien mais de cette période il reste
des choses l'idée qu' on peut imaginer
le monde différemment
c'est important quand vous êtes dans un
monde sans bord voyez
tout le monde est entièrement globalisé
par le capitalisme financier il n'y a
pas de bord vous pouvez pas aller
quelque part où il ya plus de
capitalisme financier ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas même dans la la plus
profonde tribu l'appui perdu quelqu'un
un objet un truc en plastique ou un
autre on est obligé de dire on n'entre
pas en contact ou alors on est là avec
les tribus les plus perdus pour qu'il
entende pas parler de nous et surtout
nos microbes mais imaginez qu'un autre
monde est possible nécessite qu'on en
ait une clarté d'un alice en théorie
clair pas de pratiquer clair que je dis
là c'est pas les révolutionnaires de
1917 c'est du compte un pas d'idée
claire pas d'action clair
donc il faut repenser s'habituer à
repenser non seulement les relations
dans le monde qui est le nouvel acteur
social pour moi c'est le peuple c'est
pas le prolétariat mais aussi avec
d'autres outils d'entrée alors le saut
mythique on connaissait avant c'était le
partage et l'égalité important ça reste
fondateur
mais en même temps il ya au passage on
s'est fait mettre dans le crâne quelques
idées qu'il va falloir mettre dehors
c'est la moins chère des malins si tu
prends moins cher avant je vais pas
limpide ailleurs si si j'ai moins cher
jeu pour attendre plus prendre plus
deuxième idée bizarre elle va de soi
pour tout le monde ils se faisaient rld
abbé pierre la butte à la hâte en a tant
à combien attendu ouais j'ai entendu
mais j'en laisse pas tirer curé l'abbé
pierre où il disait pas que des bêtises
bon mmo en tout cas ce que j'ai retenu
de ceux du créneau à bpr si j'ose dire
c'est un vieux militant qui me l'a
appris et il n'était pas à socialiste
était gaulliste et le gars il termine le
film
de mon petit camarade la sociale
et attendre si je veux quand tu à dire
un non tu les oublies bon
le film social et gilles perret et il
dit le gars y regarde l'écran est dit en
politique on peut
faire des milliers d'erreurs de faute
mais on est sûr de ne pas se tromper sur
se met du côté des pauvres
alors je sais que c'est pas un concept
très lutte de classe 1 mais
la lutte doit inclure le point de vue de
celui qui n'est plus en état de lutter
et la responsabilité de celui qui peut
lutter elle est d'assumer aussi sa part
de lutte à la place de l'autre et c'est
la raison pour laquelle 1 et de
restaurer des dix mêlée le jeu la
responsabilité morale parce qu'il ya des
gens qui nous écoutent sait déjà c'est
un public assez particulier qui va venir
écouter bon il va être peut-être
socialement un peu un peu cheap et un
cas pourquoi à ces particules parce que
parce que il faut pouvoir accéder à
l'internet thoumine y est pas deuxio
parce que il faut avoir l'appétit
des choses compliquées et s'est pas
répandue dans tout les mieux vous avez
des gens très riches qui sont d'une
stupidité insondable et qui ne
s'intéresse à rien alors qu'ils prennent
des responsabilités inouïe dans la vie
hein voilà et puis aussi dans les
milieux populaires des gens qui disent
non à tout ça c'est tout leur histoire
c'est tous des menteurs bon donc il ya
plein de raisons de penser qu'on va
avoir ici un public qui n'est pas que ça
intéresse et ce public là il faut qu'il
qu'il aille au bout de la morale qu'il
doit construire un
des fois je me fais jeter à la figure
par des types qui se croient malins ils
me disent comment vous osez parler comme
ça à vos quêtes millionnaire d'abord je
suis pas millionnaire ou plus exactement
dernières déclarations de patrimoine
pour la présidentielle c'est combien bon
appel plus mais ça faisait dix ballons
alors maintenant ça doit être plus parce
que à paris vous avez rien besoin de
faire à moi j'ai acheté les mètres
carrés au bon moment j'ai revendu j'ai
revendu j'ai attendu et maintenant alors
je suis il bouge a plus personne ne
m'enlèvera de là
j'ai déjà dit des choses pas un capital
que j'ai acheté c'est un appart les gars
donc je vous le donne si vous voulez
mais vous avez des garanties données à
moi que je suis bon bref vous l'avez
compris c'est une blague mais c'est pour
dire que quand le mètre carré augmente
en quinze ans de 350% d'accord moi j'ai
refait la peinture à l'intérieur puis
j'ai rien changé dehors je suis pour
rien si ça va mieux ça va moins bien
mais ne pas boire moi je suis pour rien
bref mais ce que je veux dire à travers
ça c'est que
la morale ne peut pas consister à dire
profiter tétouan
d'accord donc quel que soit ton niveau
de revenus est d'ailleurs il ya des gens
qui ont de l'argent et qu'ils partagent
mon combat il y en a d'autres comme on
pas et qui peuvent être des pierres donc
bien sûr la condition sociale va
déterminer l'intérêt pour un programme
vous voyez bien que quand je dis que
tout ce qu'il ya au dessus de 12
millions dans l'héritage donne aux
jeunes gens qui sont en faculté ou au
lycée professionnel bon celui qui a 35
millions ça n'enchante pas eu à dire
mais comment il prend la moitié ou 24
millions il prend la moitié mais ça va
pas parce qu'on a jamais assez ans
quand même je le jette dans la pauvreté
avec 12 millions il est clair que celui
qu'a rien il dit mais mélenchon a raison
pourquoi il leur laisse demi million
mais
celui qui a plus bon mais il peut être
d'accord voyez et on a connu des gens
qui fonctionnait comme ça c'est très
curieux ils accumulent toute leur vie
puis quand ils arrivent vers le bout et
disent ouais bon maintenant il donne
tout on a connu un simple c'est pas le
plus grand nombre puis ça n'efface pas
les méfaits dans system le système
capitaliste est pas le résultat le
capitalisme financier et de notre époque
c'est pas le résultat d'une volonté
individuelle c'est un système ils se
protègent en tant que système alors tout
ça pour dire que là ne jamais perdre de
vue qu'un engagement politique contient
un engagement moral et en engagement
philosophique des fois vous le savez pas
vous êtes dans point de vue mais vous ne
le savez pas que en même temps vous
trimballer avec vous une morale et une
philosophie de l'existence
des fois vous découvrez et puis bon bah
ou arrangés que votre conscience
on dit souvent que
l'écologie c'est un sport de bobo riche
qui va acheter ces petites tomates bio
qui va les faire ces petits choux bio
qui va prendre ses petites chaussures en
cuir bio
selon cuir il a en plus de mes gars me
lance mal mais ouais il faut pas se
moquer des gens et comment on fait quand
on est pris dans ce système
d'hyperconsommation capitalistique avec
un salaire de misère qu'on est obligé de
manger des tomates dopé à x 1 30 dans
qu'on est obligé de manger du poulet
dopé qui vit sur de la merde je te
parler à ces gens là
on devient inaudible en leur disant
voilà le bon marché ça coûte cher
quand quelqu'un quand quand la majorité
est dans la survie déjà en mangeant des
produits pas chers développé pour ce
capitalisme qui a besoin demain déjà des
bons produits et contiennent moins de
vitamines moins d'éléments nutritifs
l'état le président il fait quoi ils
opposent il impose aux industriels
bah oui il n'a pas le choix d'abord
commençons par par apprécier ce que vous
venez de dire dans son fondant non
l'écologie c'est pas un sport de bobo il
s'agit de l'intérêt général humain si
vous n'êtes pas le comptant les crever
dans votre coin mais comprenez que les
autres essayent de faire autre chose
j'ai compris j'ai très bien compris mais
vous faites bien de le faire parce qu'il
faut poser cet argument sur la table y
sert à discréditer un combat alors je
veux bien que ici ou là il peut y avoir
des excès 1,2 des gens qui se comportent
comme des donneurs de leçons parce que
souvent ils sont même pas conscients du
mal qui font dire le titre qu'il a mais
je vais vous donner un exemple vous
allumez votre télé ou taper une campagne
sur les 5 fruits et légumes qu'il faut
manger tous les jours pour bien se
porter et c mais vous avez un tas de
gens mais on peut pas manger ça me fout
et légumes ça coûte trop cher mais
imaginez-vous l'humiliation que c'est
vous la pub pas si vous êtes avec vos
gosses et vous allez votre gosse qui est
premier de la classe parce qu'il
travaille bien et l'autre qui suis qui
je suis qui s'intéresse à tout dit
pourquoi manges face à de fruits et
légumes papa pourquoi on n'a pas ça le
fruit légume ah non il n'y avait pas
cinq fruits et légumes aujourd'hui toi
tu racontes tu réponds quoi qu'est ce
que tu veux répondre j'ai vu une fois en
ga pas loin de chez moi là il avait ses
deux petits à la main et il passe devant
un marchand de fruits à paris et le
marchand de fruits dans des petites
bananes voiliers et globale à dire des
petites bananes ça va être un petit prix
il les prend et au moment de payer je l'
ai vu il reposer dit merci et s'en va
avec les deux âges avaient le coeur en
cendres
j'ai compris ce que ça voulait dire bref
donc on rigole pas avec ça on le prend
au sérieux tout le monde a le droit
d'avoir le bon manger des fois arrêter
de raconter des salades pour faire ça
peut changer le système
vous pouvez pas le faire autrement si
vous partagez pas la richesse vous ne
pouvez pas augmenter les salaires si
vous augmentez pas les salaires et les
minimums sociaux les gens peut pas
s'acheter le bon manger par conséquent
le progrès social ces du progrès
écologique à la sortie alors un
rectifier la situation jeudi toujours ça
m'amuse de dire ça augmenter le smic
c'est écolo a commencé écolo va si bien
tout simplement parce que ça va nous
aider à payer les produits au prix où on
doit les payer c'est un problème
politico économique très important dans
notre société pendant tout l'été les
trente glorieuses qui était pas si
glorieuse que ça pour tout le monde ils
ont réussi à faire tomber le prix de
l'alimentation de 20% du budget à 9% ça
veut dire 11 points de gagnés sur le dos
des paysans et de la qualité de ce qu'on
mange alors aujourd'hui vous voulez pas
entend très bien fait comme vous
l'entendez pas assez pour produire plus
moins cher en avant du glyphosate
partout monsieur mélenchon ça coûte
moins cher c'est vous qui allez arracher
l'herbe sur mélenchon serait ainsi de
suite tout ses blagues de rustres un bon
et bien très bien donc il n'est pas
d'agriculture avant que vous ayez
inventé le glyphosate
j'en ai mangé quoi ils broutent et les
arbres non il y avait une agriculture
alors arrêtez de nous prendre pour des
imbéciles d'accord d'ailleurs il ya
plein de paysans quand décidé ils
veulent plus mettre de pesticides bon
donc en les pesticides vous n'avez pas
voulu vous avez mis partout et vous
voulez continuer et ben non pourquoi
parce que maintenant 90 % des rivières
contiennent du pesticide vous allez
faire pipi cook on analyse ça vous est
contaminée alors ça vous a pas suffi ce
qui s'est passé aux antilles avec le
chlordécone pareil on leur a dit que
c'est pas grave c'est pour les bananes
et puis ça tue le verre des bana la
roche prend un verre j'aime pas les
banales donc pas de problème un bain 6
99% des gens en fait une prise de sang
on trouve du chlordécone on sait que
c'est un entier et ça ça a été fait
délibérément parce que les états unis
l'ont arrêté dans les années 70 et nous
en france on arrêtait en 90 sauf dans
les antilles ou encore mis trois ans
pour finir les stocks un autre jour un
petit bout de pain pour finir le petit
bout de fromage puis un petit bout de
fromage pour finir le petit bout de pain
et avec le glyphosate c'est ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire alors quand le
maquereau est arrivé il a dit bien moi
je vais arrêter ça alors bon ça c'était
au début après a dit dans trois ans
il va l'europe est là bas ils ont dit ah
on dans cinq ans appuie d'ailleurs pas
dans 50 dans cinq ans on en reparle donc
il continue un petit bout de pain pour
un petit bout de fromage etc etc donc
moi je l'interdirait
ça c'est la contrainte alors on me dit
c'est pas possible du jour au lendemain
il faudra vous y faire tomber nos moyens
ben c'est pas moi dessus paysage pas
comme on fait un mais vous si vous savez
non c'est votre métier un métier leurs
études de 100000 où sont passés les
autres et tous les trois jours il
s'empare de misère de solitude de dégoût
alors qu'est ce que c'est votre truc
alors les gens mangent mal ce qu'ils
mangent
ils absorbent des saloperies les gens
qui le font verdon nuit
meurt de deux solitudes et meurent de
tension et puis en plus ils meurent de
maladies qui se refilent eux mêmes en
mettant les produits que vous leur a dit
quelle est la logique de votre système à
quoi ça sert c'est la raison pour
laquelle
quand on préparait le programme s'étend
des hasards un bon et un petit peu 3
quelque chose en agriculture parce que
j'ai été journaliste cette branche est
enfin non modestement et puis après il
se trouve que le hasard de la vie fait
que ans mais bon copain qui a fondé avec
moi le parti de gauche à l'époque
il s'appelle laurent levard c'est un
agronome et c'est lui qui a mis promis
au point un programme donc le premier
programme qu'on a eue quand on lui
quitté le ps un programme agricole grâce
à lui et participe toujours d'ailleurs
au travail commun avec moi et je je lui
dois beaucoup alors donc
je connais le problème que ça soulève
pas de glyphosate ça va coûter plus cher
à ben oui dans la boutique plus cher et
on n'achètera pas moins cher parce que
j'interdirais aux produits qui
contiennent du glyphosate d'entrées en
france le plus gros consommateur de
glyphosate en france le plus gros
consommateur de glyphosate en france et
qui sait la sncf
non
non c'est la vigne
anor de glyphosate pardon de pesticides
c'est la ville non là oui ça doit être
la sncf c'est possible je sais pas joker
je crois que vous avez raison peut-être
que la sncf ait décidé d'arrêter des
halles a bien fait je vous coupe dans le
raisonnement je suis désolé je vais juil
additionnez un facteur débilitants à
tout ça qui est l'inflation qu'on est en
train de se prendre sur l'énergie
l'énergie le pétrole ces deux-là
calories
qui ensuite transformés en engrais en
gros on mange du pétrole maintenant
comme le prix de l'eau du pétrole
augmentent la bouffe augmente en plus de
tous les effets délétères de l'hyper
production je vous en passe comment on
fait quand on
veut devenir président de la république
quand on sait qu'on va se taper 10 %
d'inflation au ne parlait pas d'un
bonheur pareil ça réduit les dettes
c'est ça
d'abord alors il ya deux sujets
l'inflation une augmentation des
salaires il a écouté pas moi qui vais
pleurer c'est une lutte de classe parce
que pourquoi en europe le banquier
central
indien a pas faire comme les américains
pas se met à tousser ray pourquoi parce
que et le tipi a bien compris que si
jamais ils resserrent les boulons mais
le temps que l'inflation s'efface si
jamais il y arrive il va y avoir une
unité une montée des luttes donkey 10h
continuera m treize ont pris l'habitude
d'en mettre de tous les côtés et ce
système ne durera que ce qui est dur
mais l'inflation actuelle
pour a une origine qui est pas celle à
laquelle on s'attendait à l'origine à
laquelle on s'attendait sait on a
tellement mis de monnaie en circulation
que bon elle correspond pas il va leur
matériel produite donc l'ajustement se
fait par l'inflation car en fait la
monnaie monde qu'elle m'aurait hancock
et il n'y a rien derrière y a pas de
valeur matérielle derrière ça c'est ce
qui va se produire mais attendez les
gens partent tout de suite ça vient ça
vient les américains en ont mis un tel
paquet en circulation que alors la
chance qu'on a c'est que dans la sphère
financière ils s'amusent entre eux et
comme personne ne revient avec les
billets pour acheter des choses réelles
ou pour les mettre en mouvement réel on
a on a toujours un décalage et
l'inflation ne ne se transmet pas si
facilement qu'avant mais quand même un
jour ou l'autre rite des actions sur
l'autre quelques a valu le prix des
actions c'est monstrueux si vous
comparez le progrès du prix des actions
ces gens que ça plus au foot leur fric
kilomètres là dedans et qui joue sur le
fait que ça augmente bombay les tarifs
vont pas monter jusqu'au ciel dans les
arbres non plus n'y arrive pas donc tu
n'y a pas de raison que les cours de la
bourse qui arrive donc à un moment donné
il ya ce qu'ils appellent des
corrections c'est une catastrophe
gigantesque pour tout le monde enfin
pour tous ceux qui sont sous sa palette
est traumatisée la catastrophe ici la
catastrophe là bas puis bon le lendemain
on reconstruit le système c'est ça qui
rend capitalisme financier si dangereux
c'est qu'il est incapable de se corriger
pour la raison qu'elle vit des désastres
qui produit c'est la première fois qu'on
voit ça dans l'histoire tous les autres
systèmes ont été condamnés par leur
incapacité à ce que ceux qui
n'arrivaient pas à se corriger prenons
par exemple la bureaucratie soviétique
bon elle était incapable de corriger
faute de démocratie les décisions
absurdes qu'elle prenait comme par
exemple accepter la course aux armements
avec les états unis donc s'ils ont coupé
les veines pour se payer ça et pourquoi
tout simplement parce que les militaires
étaient en nombre suffisant dans la
bureaucratie pour dire allah vous
touchez pas à ça et là bas si vous
voulez mais pas nous bref comme n'y
avait pas de régulateur collectif pas le
plus fort a eu le dernier mot plus fort
c'est le plus bête donc il a fait ce
qu'il en fût du parterre l'union
soviétique je prends cet exemple parce
que c'est le plus récent dans l'histoire
récente mais là ce capitalisme lui
profite des dégâts là on vient de se
taper le la crise du duc au vide ils se
sont taris a terminé non ce n'est pas
terminé mais et puis que vous allez voir
la suivante si vous avez aimé le coc
vite vous allez adorer la grippe aviaire
ou je sais pas quoi après parce que le
jour où mute parce qu'on n'a pas eu le
temps de terminer tout à l'heure le
raisonnement mais le jour où le virus de
la grippe aviaire mutait l'être humain
bonjour tout le monde on croise les
doigts pour que ça se produise pas mais
en france là c'est chaud pour nous en ce
moment le nombre d'élevages on est en
train de tuer des millions de bestioles
et or le j'ose dire le plus terrible
c'est que la grippe aviaire ça concerne
pas les oeufs et la viande ça concerne
l'export donc on tue des millions de
bestioles pour pouvoir être en état d'en
exporter aussitôt qu'on veut tous c'est
absurde une agriculture qui ne vit que
par ce qu'elle exporte vous avez accepté
le marché global on me dit mais qu'est
ce qu'on va faire si on fait pas ça ben
faire à manger il faut faire de
l'agriculture vivrière à quoi ça sert
d'aller fabriquer du maïs pour nourrir
des poules en chine on va ensuite ramené
cette absurde autant faire les poules
ici et puis chaque fois que vous ferez
du soja en argentine rien là là là du
soja en argentine pour nourrir des
bestioles ici donc nous et c'est fou
donc pile de mes tâches avec de niro
rétabli l'agriculture vivrière mais
comme je suis pas fou je me suis
renseigné je suis et frisant défini
définitivement avec les yaka les gens
qui vous dira enfin il faut dire qu'à il
ya 4,6 à café à la wet tu fais comment
qui c'est qui va faire de l'agriculture
vivrière après me le dire ils sont où
les trois cent mille paysans dont j'ai
besoin affolée trouvait donc falloir
faire autre chose qu'une vie comme celle
que vous leur faites donc il en faut
plus il faut qu'ils puissent travailler
par roulement faut accepter le pays de
payer le prix des choses et pour payer
le prix des choses faut que les salaires
soient bons pour quel salaire soit bon
faut que c'est pas la pente où l'hôte a
rien qu'on peut pas dire qui acclama ce
de ce qu'on produit et la masse de la
richesse et diminué dans ce pays et donc
il ya de quoi mais alors après je
raconte pas d'histoires c'est une belle
organisation
ça fera pas plaisir à tout le monde et
ceux à qui ça va pas faire plaisir c'est
des plus puissants c'est eux qui
dominent des moyens de communication qui
sont capables vous avez vu ça dit
lui-même là je vais pas dire le nom du
pdg george me rappelle pas qui a dit à
bas l'armée au et c'est moi le patron je
n'ai pas l'intention du tout de voir mon
journal les échos développer des thèses
marxistes alors dont ils se rassurent il
n'y a pas trace de maxime dans les échos
qu'un très bon journal par ailleurs mais
je le lis tous les jours mais en tout
cas
en tout cas il a dit il n'a pas dit mais
non pas du tout alors ils disent
important de grands noms ça peut être la
ligne dans real alors on termine sur
l'agriculture il faut donc à que les
gens soient prêts pour qu'ils soient
prêts qu'ils aient envie il faut une
prise de conscience et il faut que les
conditions de vie sous vos râble vous
pouvez pas annoncer à des gens qui vont
aller à la campagne par prendre comme ça
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 toi tu vas à la
campagne c'est possible le schéma où
c'est ça déjà on n'est pas chez mao pour
commencer et puis ceux qui l'ont fait
ont jamais rien réussi un mao je voulais
faire des fonderies pour faire de
l'acier alors ils ont pris les paysans
leur diouf est de l'acier les résultats
il ya eu ni bleynie acier à ça a été
grandiose comme comme comme méthode les
sociétés humaines ne peuvent pas se
manier à la trique voilà et alors vous
pouvez avoir l'illusion que c'est plus
efficace je sais pas quel genre
d'illusions ils ont eu cette année là
parce qu'il ya eu du monde inquiet mort
de cette invention d'ailleurs les
dirigeants chinois ont plus voulu de
cette ligne pour ça que l'autre a perdu
le pouvoir c'est pas que là donc ça
c'est pas la bonne méthode la méthode
c'est la commission l'intérêt et vous
êtes plein de gens cons qui ont envie
qu'un raid visant la conviction
l'intérêt
quand je crée des mesures aussi à
prendre les mesures à bamako puis
l'apéritif aux actes bon bah un tulle a
interdit donc faut assumer et après on
va dire bon bah alors on interdit quand
est produit dans lequel il ya du
glyphosate
les convictions le sens j'étudie
j'étudie beaucoup edger j'écoute
beaucoup oui je regarde beaucoup les
insoumis les les insoumis vous vos
électeurs vos militants y en a de toutes
sortes
la plupart sont bienveillants
contrairement au contraire à d'autres
formations politiques la la la plupart
sont bienveillants à quelques fanatiques
mais n'aura génisson ouais je dirais
plus fanatiques enragé
mais la plupart sont bienveillants à la
merci s'est dit pas merci sévérité on
les voit bien ça me fait plaisir va de
l'entendre sources anonymes ercis
d'habitude on billets comme une bande de
sauvages après c'est pas vrai c'est les
premiers à se donner la main ils sont
solidaires et s'échangent des bouquins
quand y'en a un qui est dans la merde un
autre qui débarque pour l'aider quand
ils ont des points de vue différents et
les échanges il se tape pas sur la
gueule tout de suite
c'est une expérience que que j'ai depuis
à peu près sept ans à regarder écouter
les militants politiques et chez vous
ils sont ils sont plus relax ils sont
mais vous n'êtes que 13 % donc développé
de la conviction développer du sens
comment vous allez faire pour irradier
essaimé ses valeurs alors que notre
société en perte de sens total que que
que les convictions les gamins fantasme
plus sur une [__] à dubaï ou au
qatar qui fait de l'évasion fiscale qui
ce qui suit silicone et 25 fois les
lèvres et j'en passe et des meilleurs
comme comment on fait pour se battre
face
si je vais pas dire cette perte de sens
comment on fait pour remettre dans la
tête des gamins autre chose que des
footballeur qui se paye des caisses à je
ne sais pas quel prix comment et qui
combattre l'épidémie
moi j'appelle ça l'épidémie d'e
instagram euse
influence us donc relais de propagande
comment on fait pour mettre des graines
dans la tête des mouches
d'abord
on essaye de comprendre ce qui se passe
et de pas être trop
par rapport à soi même devant son miroir
pas trop donneurs de leçons pas se dire
moi je sais et puis vous
le même homme qui se passionnent pour
une bêtise comme vous a coûté pas
d'histoire vous devez aussi avoir des
passions ridicule dont vous ne parlerez
pas la voiture sur soi la patience il ya
des gens qui disent mais qu'est ce que
vous faites et la poterie et obtient
alors de mieux en mieux de mieux en
mieux vous faites de la poterie
avec quoi vous gravé dessus du petit
bois et voilà vous savez que j'ai un
grand nom vous savez pas j'ai un grand
rêve que j'ai dit à des archéologues
j'aurais dit vous allez pouvoir trouver
des fonds d sont fausses il un jour ou
l'autre parce que les poteries du fond
du temps de l'humanité elles ont été
faites pas un type qui veut dire zut
pour être poli 1 j'ai encore raté le
tout dans une langue qu'on ne connaît
pas ou bien s'adresser à son boss haut à
sa femme et lui dire quelque chose donc
un jour on trouvera des sons fossiles on
a déjà trouvé des troncs fossiles avec
des pierres on a on a retrouvé dans un
salon fille parenté c'est mon tour donc
on trouve des pierres aujourd'hui du du
nu sur les rings alors on y trouve des
pierres et ils ont compris que ces
fameuses pierres on pouvait taper dessus
c'était comme des xylophone et on
reproduit les sons que les légendes
réécoutais et c'est la musique qui se
connectent veneta par la partition est
là pas la partition c'est quand j'ai
raconté ça les archéologues ça les a
fait marrer et il faut dire que l'idée
m'est venue en lisant une nouvelle de
science fiction c'est qui je me rappelle
plus hélas je me rappelle plus et le
gars avait inventé il y avait un verre
qui avait une qualité particulière c'est
qu'il arrêtait la lumière et puis il a
laissé passer mais au bout d'un temps
donc qu'on voyait de l'autre côté dans
la nouvelle de science fiction ça
d'exercice et la lumière ouais donc tu
voyais le spectacle de il ya un an où il
ya deux ans qui apparaissait derrière le
vert alors le truc était assez bien fait
parce que c'était une enquête policière
et le policier qui faisait son enquête
s'était aperçu que le vert du pare brise
était de 7 du beurre enfin du crime
était de cette nature là donc ils
reconstituent et le pare brise pour
avoir l'image bref j'adore les
anticipations qui nous font regarder les
objets différemment parce que c'est
voulu me parler de poterie la vote de
poterie je suis sûr qu'en tant que j'ai
collé ça dans la tête plus jamais vous
ferez une poterie en sifflotant mais en
parlant ça veut dire mes hanches on m'a
dit que je suis en train de graver
dans dix mille ans ou peut-être
peut-être juste dans dix ans que
quelqu'un va trouver vous parlez de la
signature bah oui non mais quand vous et
quand vous gravé dessus non mais vous
avez un tour vous faites le tour comme
ça mais je monte au colombin comme ça
d'accord la base avec des petits bouts
de web et vous avez entoure donc pas
obligatoirement
entoure c'est bien pour justement pour
les sont fausses il sait pas où on est
parti là dans l'histoire mais non ça va
ça va nous éloigner et et nous
rapprocher de
delibes une certaine
on va remettre en cause les évidences
c'était ça votre point de départ les
choses qui nous paraissent évidentes qui
sont depuis toujours là celle que nous
avons intériorisé la rue les joies là
mais d'abord je vais vous dire une chose
je nomme ça a toujours été comme ça sauf
ça tu veux que je nomme je vous appelez
vieux dans pas longtemps si vous voulez
moi ça me fera pas il appelait léon
trotsky comme ça et moi j'ai appelé
françois mitterrand le vieux mais pardon
je retire le jeune homme parce que
c'était juste pour vous peut-être
au-delà de vous parmi ceux qui
m'écoutent qui pose cette question parce
qu elle existe elle est vraiment posé je
leur dis souvent mais quand est ce que
vous croyez que ça a été facile parce
que il ya des lois qui viennent me voir
du temps où la classe ouvrière étaient
concentrés dans des grandes usines c'est
bien connu c'était le socialisme et
pourtant ils étaient concentrés et
pourtant ils étaient exploités et on a
créé un syndicat et puis ensuite on a
créé un parti et puis le parti s'est
coupé en deux et puis en 3 parce que
l'adversaire il avait l'art aussi on y
met les doigts pour que tout dégénère et
puis soi même on y mettait tout là bref
ça n'a jamais été facile et puis pardon
pour je veux pas offenser les croyants
mais quand vous aviez fini la semaine de
travail touly d'aller à l'église et le
curé vous disais ce qu'il fallait penser
à ne dit pas le contraire c'était comme
ça donc il ya toujours eu une idéologie
dominante des appareils idéologiques de
non mon bas après chacun se remet en
cause aujourd'hui
les curés catholique je crois pas qu'ils
prêchent le libéralisme de ce que je
crois savoir moi en tout cas j'ai des
bons copains qui sont de la théologie de
la libération il c'est pas ça qui
prêchent un bon alors ou même le pape
sait pas si vous avez lu son encyclique
fratelli tutti ou celle d'avant là où
date et si moi je les lis tout par
intérêt pour
l'attaquant
français je serais plus on l'attend j'ai
su mais je saurai plus
je serai plus mais bref tout ça pour
vous dire la lutte contre l'idéologie
dominante c'est surtout contre la
domination d'idéologie ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que il faut accepter
de mettre en cause que ce dans quoi nous
croyons que nous vivons comme une
évidence n'est pas une évidence est un
produit du temps des circonstances des
rapports de forces sociales qui
deviennent des rapports de force
culturelle et la marque reste
indépassable l'idéologie dominante et
l'idéologie de la classe dominante
concrètement concrètement le gamin c'est
un nouveau mot d'ordre aujourd'hui
concrètement un pragmatiquement alors
d'accord ok ok le gamin il fait quoi
pour pour changer ses rêves mais ne
change pas ses rêves ça va pas non mais
le laisserait comme il veut d'abord il
est plus conscient que ce que vous
croyez mais comme tout le monde il a
bien compris que la planète est foutue
entière peut être d'autres conclusions
alors ils s'arrangent avec eux ça
conscient mais qu'est ce que vous faites
vous qu'est ce que je fais moi toute la
journée on s'arrange avec notre
conscience nous ont dit ah bon alors
faut pas faire si tu le fais quand même
bon mois faut que j'arrête de boire
autant de café du matin au soir ben j'en
bois à chaque fois en faisant bon ok
j'arrête après voilà celui qui arrive
pas à arrêter de fumer moi je sais ce
que ça a coûté le jour où il a fallu
arrêter bonjour ça a été dur là ça fait
un mois qu'on parle ou alors c'est une
esthétique idéologie dominante ça passe
par des d'abord faire confiance ne
jamais se dire celui à qui je parle pas
crétin qui comprendra jamais rien parce
qu'il est trop bête parce que ceci parce
que cela parce que les gens très bête et
crétin pour ne rien comprendre c'est une
petit infime minorité la masse des gens
et bienveillante et elle se dit comment
bien faire et qu'est-ce que je peux
faire de bien de ma vie les gens
méchants fondamentalement tordus sont
sont finalement peu nombreux à d'abord
arrêter d'en parler tout le temps si on
passe son temps à mettre en scène le
crime abominable à tel endroit talent
moyens en a toujours eu alors bien sûr
c'est abominable mais ne parlons pas que
de ça ne voyons pas la vie qui à travers
ça voyons là à travers tous ces gens qui
font des trucs extraordinaires ils vont
à l'école pour apprendre ils ont hâte de
bien faire leur métier aujourd'hui vous
prenez le moindre jeune qui est dans
n'importe quelle branche de
l'enseignement professionnel il regarde
le les matériaux qu'on fait utilisé il
dit mais c'est quoi ça ça va ou ou cinq
ans de balance 1 j'ai parlé avec l'autre
jour avec des étés au musée de
l'imprimerie égal mais ils m'ont montré
sa machine il me dit on mettait de
l'acide pour faire les plaques il dit
rendant foutu en l'air 500 litres tous
les jours dans la flotte aujourd'hui
personne m m et même une une tâche
qu'est ce que je suis en train de faire
par contre foot du glyphosate partout il
n'a pas l'air de les déranger ben si ça
valait le sabbat les déranger comment on
fait pour faire remonter 13 % à + ça
dépend des circonstances d'abord un il
faut être patient deux se dire qu'on
lutte contre quelque chose de très
puissant qui n'est pas que l'ennemi que
vous connaissez l'adversaire qui va être
le dominant de la société mais que
l'ennemi a pris pied en vous vous disiez
tout à l'heure comment on peut faire
tout le monde est obligé de faire des
compromis il faut arriver à rompre le
compromis dans un beau rapport de force
si vous allez au boulot mettons que vous
aimiez votre travail je mets ça de côté
vous réalisez dans votre travail une
sorte dit ouais mais en même temps vous
perdez pas de vue que progressivement
nous et c'est à voir votre vie le nombre
de ceux c'est pas grave je vous c'est
pareil mais non vous êtes fait avoir
votre vie non ben moi je suis à part
mais oubliez pas mais non mais je veux
dire le travail il produit une richesse
vous la partagez moi j'ai rien à
partager que des idées plus j'ai partagé
puis on a donc ça va mais quand on
partage la richesse on parle d'autre
chose si vous faites c'est cramé votre
vie si vous avez passé votre temps vous
dévouez pour une entreprise à revenir à
la maison avec le portable sous le bras
et à pourrir votre week end avec parce
que le droit à la déconnexion turlututu
c'est pipeau aujourd'hui 1 donc il va
falloir qu on règle ça aussi et bien et
combien de gens qui ont aujourd'hui la
quarantaine commence à dire hé ho
pourquoi j'ai fait tout ça moi pourquoi
je mène une vie de chien d'accord je
suis bien payé mais pour quoi faire et
ça beaucoup sont dans cette
interrogation ça c'est pour ceux qui
avaient les meilleures places et
meilleur job en général ce qu'avaient
les diplômes les plus avancés tout ça et
puis les autres qui sont dans des tâches
plus répétitives minimes c'est quoi le
sens de la vie s'il faut juste marne et
comme une bête que tu me tues mise tout
sur tes enfants tu dis bon il vaut mieux
vivre comme on fait les miens je vous
raconte pas le jour où chevaux venus
avec le bac j'étais là la star dans la
maison la famille personne ne l'a vu à
part moi la licence de philo or là
c'était là les gens mes pauvres parents
grands parents tous halal à jean-luc en
philosophe bon vous misez tout sur votre
gosse il revient avec le bon diplôme et
quoi il au chômage et quoi personne
n'ose rien moi partout où je passe comme
je vais lever dans les grandes écoles
comme dans l'est des endroits où on
n'est pas dans la grande école dans une
dans une formation professionnelle a
toujours dit la même chose vous préviens
si c'est moi qui gagne falloir se
retrousser les manches parce qu'il faut
que vous me régler le problème de
l'accès à une énergie haute tenue claire
la papa dans son temps ok j'ai un
premier calendrier on arrête en 2050
parce qu'on arrête progressivement mais
moi je vous demande d'aller plus vite
parce que j'ai pas confiance dans ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire je n'ai
pas confiance en eux quand ils me disent
mais non vous inquiétez pas c'est sûr
alors si c'est sûr pourquoi ton ferme
quatre sur dix pourquoi tu as découvert
dans trois centrales que le système de
refroidissement il y avait des fissures
dedans d'où ça vient que vous avez mal
formés les gens qui ont fabriqué cet
acier que vous voulu faire du moins cher
même en prenant des normes de sécurité
le problème du nucléaire il est pas
idéologique il est concret il est
pratique donc ça vole à cheval et à
nantes voir l'école d'ingénieurs
formidable alors on peut dire c'est des
gosses de riches
mais attends c'est rien c'est des lauzes
de la csp plus haut pas raconter une
histoire la majorité hayat sûrs d'eux
des gens qui viennent de tous les
milieux mais pour autant est ce qu'ils
m'ont dit oh ma ce que vous racontez je
m'en fous bon moi je veux faire la bonne
carrière j'ai avoir la bonne paye pas du
tout il ne parle que de technique on va
pouvoir faire si on pourra faire là ça
on peut pas ça monsieur mélenchon un nom
et moi je leur pose que des questions de
cette nature je leur ai demandé on peut
le oui ou non faire de l'éolien offshore
qui nous qui me donne l'équivalent avec
une dizaine une cinquantaine de 12
éoliennes offshore équivalent à rien le
raisonnement c'était un peu mon cas
c'était quoi c'est off shore ou tablier
sur des éoliennes de nouvelle génération
à un roman maximum et plein pot pour
repasser les réacteurs ça tient la route
si on accepte de pousser un peu le
raisonnement mais pour l'instant c'est
par ici sur
le nucléaire il en est comme ça on
savait pas le faire quand d'une table on
a acheter les licences ou est ce imad
lahoud et les français on commence à
rajouter des trucs jusqu'à ce que
c'était pour d'autres choses à la sortie
donc là record de file programme
thermonucléaire avec perd la raison des
reports pidoux ainsi de suite les
bateaux moi c'était pour avoir la bombe
donc commencer par avec ça on va y venir
à la bresse que la diffusion en iran
venir on va y venir pas de problème fois
quand même comme on pensa qu'il faut que
ça s'arrête mais bon ça s'arrêtera pas
non mais d'accord mais moi au matin nous
attend j'ai pas pris de montres et ben
moi j'ai pas de me tourner à une réunion
qui c'est vrai ou non je vous ferai
encore le vous raconter ma vie non mais
bon bref dre stosur
il semblerait qu'on est là ah bon donc
en attendant mais moi je peux rester
neuf heures dans des trains alors
revenons sur le sujet que vous abordez
c'est un peu bancal non je vous laisse
pas dire ça sans répondre sinon ce n'est
pas bon call parce que la première
éolienne offshore en mer est lié
française l expérimental
c'est à dire qu'elle a des pales qui
font que 40 m il faut qu'on passe à
beaucoup plus que ça a pratiquement seul
à faire 120 mètres à la fin ça se
clarifie les médias il faut front des
éoliennes verticales
oui mais il y en a des horizontales
d'autres qui sont dans des boîtes vous
inquiétez pas je suis bien nous rendre
tous à l'énergie de la merde ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire avec la condition de s'y
mettre d'accord pas de faire de la flûte
la mer contient 66 fois l'énergie dont
on a besoin sur terre bon là où en ce
moment je le raconte on a une machine à
faire de la pour refroidir l'hôpital de
papeete qui fonctionne sur le système de
l'eau froide au fond au chaud dans la
machine tourne et on arrive à produire
l'air froid dont on a besoin donc il
faut pas raconter d'histoires si on s'y
met on sait le faire on est encore une
grande nation technicienne le problème
maintenant on peut peut-être avoir c'est
que vous avez des têtes pour mettre au
point la machine nous lé pas les bras
pour la fabriquer ou là les matières
premières et les cerveaux ça c'est pas
grave on trouve toujours là on est sûr
mais tout va réouvrir des mines en
france dès des mines de quoi non j'en ai
les matériaux composites on peut faire
plein de choses est ce qu est ce qu on
va être obligé de réouvrir des mines en
france ligne de quoi mais de terreur de
lithium de toutes ces [__] guanine de
liqueur verrons bien vous me disiez à la
fin ça m'intéresse à un parent en
bolivie avec la saumure lahoud accord
est ce qu a fait transférer notre
dépendance à la chine ailleurs qu'en
chine est-ce qu'on va transférer notre
dépendance à l'arabie saoudite ou à la
russie comment faut le vouloir d'abord
non mais on peut dire non vous dire
monsieur mélenchon n'est que vous le
raconter pourquoi les troubles à bayac à
le faire venir d'ailleurs on y arrive
qu'est-ce que vous sous les bons mais
non et on peut prendre le problème par
l'autre bout et dire combien il nous
faut de temps pour devenir moi ma
l'insee il faut être indépendant et
souverain dans tous les domaines pas
papa on peut pas être indépendant et
souverain dans tous les domaines comme
ça mais il ya des domaines où il faut
faire vite et fort et d'autres pour nous
prendre notre temps pour voir 27 avec
l'euro à 27 oui on peut faire pas mal de
bêtises j'ai déjà cinq est à portée de
main bon j'y viendrai mais laissez-moi
terminé pour répondre à votre idée donc
nous
sommes capables d'avoir un système
d'éoliennes offshore en mer je dis bien
en mer parce que je suis d'accord pour
dire que la beauté c'est un bien
précieux et qu'on est pas oublier de
saloper tous les paysages d'accord n'est
pas obligé de le dire si on peut pas
faire autrement on le fait quand on a
mis les pylônes à haute tension on
pouvait pas passer ailleurs que là où on
passait donc on est passé mais si on
peut alors on se pose la question est
d'ailleurs les pylônes à haute tension
si on pouvait transporter l'énergie
parce qu'on a fait des progrès dans les
recherches qu'on peut enterrer beaucoup
de ces choses-là bon bah on le fera donc
fort le goût de la science mais après
attendait pas que au bout faire les
beaux schémas les belles machines
dessinée il vous faut derrière
tout ce qu'ils savent faire des bateaux
de service deuxio monter dans les
bateaux de service pour faire le service
fabriquer les matériaux donc ça veut
dire des paquets de métier qui
s'apprennent dans l'enseignement
professionnel maintenance des systèmes
automatisés
metallerie moteur etc etc etc donc c'est
toute la chaîne qu'il faut reconstruire
et pas seulement la mentalité qui est
aujourd'hui celle qui est au pouvoir et
on comprend c'est leur formation le
président quel est son principal défaut
c'est ça c'est que il est persuadé que
vous mettez un paquet de dollars d'un
côté un paquet de tonneaux l'autre mieux
il sort des bagnoles et ils oublient
qu'il faut du monde tout le long qui
sait faire je caricature un peu hein
mais c'est pour donner l'idée de montrer
que on doit partir de l'ensemble de la
chaîne de production et de sa
construction ou reconstruction
je vous ai dit la difficulté pour
l'agriculture tout à l'heure dans
l'industrie c'est pareil donc moi mon
idée c'est de créer des centres
polytechnique dont tout le pays sur la
base des lycées professionnels qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans lequel on fait
l'ensemble des formations depuis le ca
paix jusqu'au bts y compris pour peser
sur la psychologie des jeunes gens parce
que quand ils rentrent pour faire ses
affaires en général vous en morceaux
avant il faut d'abord qu'ils se
reconstruise qui apprennent confiance en
eux alors pour les amener jusqu'au bac
pro dont on a besoin faut les pousser
dans le dos pour qu'ils prennent
confiance en eux mais quand tu y es à
bts alors ils disent à bac pro c'est
plus facile je vous parle là de petites
choses concrètes mais vous m'avez
demandé des choses concrètes je vous
réponds des choses concrètes et loga ou
la fille qui m'ont seulement apprend un
métier mais apprend ce qui va avec le
métier c'est à dire ça qu'on lui dit
c'est bien d'être utile aux autres pas
seulement débrouille toi pour courant
pourtant prendre le plus c'est de me la
réponse à la question avant celle là
vous m'avez dit comment on fait je vais
vous dire une chose très importante je
vous donne un exemple
j'étais à la réunion et ont célébré la
fin de l' esclavage alors bon c'était
magnifique l'endroit où emmener je vous
raconte pas ça sinon ça à prendre une
heure et j'allais m'en aller je suis à
l'aéroport et je croise un gars qui
vient il vient vers moi et me salue tout
ça il dit voilà je suis prof
d'anthropologie à parler pour la rentrée
prologis lomu magique pour moi donc je
commence à discuter avec lui et puis
main braquons des choses je dit écoutez
je voudrais vous poser une question qui
met mal à l'aise ya qu à vous je peux la
pause et
puisqu'il y avait sans arrêt des
révoltes d'esclaves
tout le temps par petites tâches
pourquoi il ya eu 6 rarement des
révoltes généralisé avant la révolution
de 89 et la grande révolution telle
qu'elle a eu à saint domingue et où il
m'a dit une chose magique cet homme il
m'a dit avant
la révolte était individuelle
parce qu'il n'y avait pas l'idée qu'on
avait des droits universels à partir du
moment où on proclame qu'il ya un droit
universel que tous les êtres humains ont
vocation à être semblable parce qu'ils
le sont et avoir des droits égaux on
change la mentalité de celui qui luttent
et l'idée pénètre en profondeur dans la
société les gens vivent les pourquoi
thierry traiter comme ça toi de quel
droit tu me [__] des coups de fouet
pourquoi je vais travailler pour toi
sans être payé et à ce moment là la
révolte de vie en général c'est la
puissance des idées les idées deviennent
des forces matérielles quand elle se
propage mais par où peuvent-elles ce
prodige propagée par à coups un tueur de
l'avant garde révolutionnaire qui vient
proclamer la vérité alors tout le monde
tombe à genoux devant la cage des mots
tu as raison moi j'ai déjà dit cent fois
des copains des banques pas que j'aime
en plus dhimmitude tu récites un
catéchisme comment veux tu qu'on écoute
d'accord on a compris on est exploité
alors c'est quoi la sortie il faut c'est
ça qu'il faut montrer quel autre nom
bref dans cette affaire la force la
puissance
de l'idée collectiviste c'est
qu'aujourd'hui elle marche - comme une
idée abstraite égalité du noël voisin il
ya le jeu hein
l'intérêt général humain la force du
collectivisme actuelle c'est la prise de
conscience écologiste parce que quand
vous comprenez qu'il ya des biens
communs que tout le monde va crever si
on change pas l'air alors c'est plus
juste un truc bobos comme 10 des
imbéciles c'est quelque chose qui
concerne tout le monde et ça vous
l'arrêté pas vous n'arrêtez pas si vous
dites un homme ou une femme tes gosses
ils vont être bizarre une fois qu'ils
auront dû en grand coup de glyphosate
pendant toute leur vie que toi tu auras
but du glyphosate toi tu vas être mal
tes enfants vont être mal c'est fini
tout d'un coup les gens y mais pourquoi
on ferait ça surtout si vous avez un
gars comme moi qui apparaît de temps à
autres circonstances de l'histoire qui
vous met dans la situation d'hier
d'autres vous êtes en train de vous
faire avoir et moi je lâcherai jamais
parce que vieux comme je suis fait plus
carrière un jeu même émoi en scène parce
que ça mais c'est pas moi seulement
c'est tout seul ou gala fille à luzy non
machin truc le premier qui résiste et
qui dit aux autres dit mais pourquoi
vous supporter un truc pareil vous savez
vous allez être les dindons de la farce
alors ça se propage voilà ma réponse et
après faut être patient
patients
et là c'est l'histoire est cruelle parce
qu'elle est longue c'est surtout à l'an
passé on se on serait industrialise
comment on va chercher les matières
premières avec les petits enfants
africains ont fait comme nous des mines
chez nous on fait comment mais là on
commence par dire ce qu'on veut faire
parce que moi je vais je m'amuse de voir
les types qui arrivent en disant il faut
réindustrialiser oui pourquoi faire
baa pour donner du boulot a très bien et
on produit quoi la sortie s'il vous
plaît eh ben ça veut rien il vaudrait
mieux que de l'industrie en france pas
parce boulade faut prendre le problème
moi je vous ai répondu pour aller mettre
50 éoliennes en mer pour faire la
puissance d'un réacteur
folie fabriquer les gars ça ça s'appelle
rien eu quand je dis rien du ce crédit
jeudi de quoi pour faire ça il faut
qu'on arrive à maîtriser complètement à
la filière hydrogène parce que tous ceux
qui sont en train de nous vendre de la
bagnole électrique
il oublie de vous dire que pour un
million de bagnols faut areter de plus
trash eh beh oui ou des centrales on
n'en parlons pas parce que tout le monde
a compris que ça c'est pas rien donc la
réindustrialisation c'est pas un
objectif en soi ce qu'un objectif c'est
ce dont nous avons besoin comment on s'y
prend pour le fabriquer est ce qu'on a
besoin de consommer moins d'énergie et
ce courant ça vaut mieux
avoir le choix de leiria est-ce qu'on
rentre en décroissance est-ce qu'on
continue la croissance
mais question est trop abstraite lee non
mais j'ai compris j'ai compris mais je
sais bien que la pause comme ça donc
vous vous êtes à un bon porte parole
louis qu une question qui se pose et on
peut pas demander tout plu à tout le
monde à les découper les cheveux en
quatre pour mieux comprendre quatre
dents mais c'est mon rôle de le faire
vous me posez la question je vous
réponds le mot décroissance il a été
inventé j'ai eu de belles discussions
avec paul ariès quel homme qui maniait
ça le plus aiguisée c'est un mot au but
il cessa obligé à la discussion que moi
comme j'ai sorti planification
écologique c'est très bien ce que
j'étais en train de faire dans la
planification tous les imbéciles de la
terre sont sortis de leur boîte pour me
dire ah c'est l'union soviétique
n'oubliez juste que la planification été
inventé par les capitalistes pas par les
soviétiques et que bombay la
planification partout mais là c'est
pareil décroissance alors l'intérêt la
victoire idéologique car emporté ceux
qui sont battus là dessus c'est qu'ils
ont permis de comprendre que la
croissance n'est pas le seul mode de
fonctionnement de la société alors comme
vous et moi on est tous pareils on
regarde on dit des croissants des
croissants ça dépend de quoi au bout de
5 minutes vous dit ça dépend de quoi oui
certaines choses vont décroître
non d'autres vont devoir croître si je
veut fabriquer les éoliennes au genou
parlera bien falloir développer ça si je
suis en train de vous dire que il faut
des bateaux de service pour desservir
tout ça faut bien les construire donc ça
c'est une activité qui va croître donc
la décroissance elle va être ciblés il
ya des choses qui vont décroître
d'autres qui vont croître il ya des
activités pardon qu'est-ce qui va
décroître et bardé consommation absurde
des consommations néfastes par exemple
il y aura une nette décroissance de la
production du glyphosate puisque ça va
être interdite je prends un exemple
caricatural mais je pourrais le prendre
dans dans d'autres domaines la
fabrication de masse des objets jetables
c'est fini bon côté de saab à tous ceux
qui ont aujourd'hui c'est des petites
entreprises qui font des couverts en
bois bas va falloir qu'ils en fassent
davantage à nous retrouver le bois les
ennemis à belize à baffes aller le
chercher qui sait quand même la machine
vous allez fabriquer kiss & kill à
mettre la pilote la machine il doit
répondre à tout ça retrouver les gens
c'est fini de se dire on s'en fout les
chinois han lors de notre beau et le
ramènent des meubles un cc pour les
suédois ça alors nous on vend notre bois
comme on est riche on vend notre bois
pour le temps de s'en occuper et puis
doit même des meubles puis alors après
rebond donne ça et puis il me ramène au
chat et à la faune c'est plus rien faire
donc tout c'est toutes ces choses au
croître il ya des métiers launay qui ont
tué le nf en virant les gens et en
mettant dans la nef une gestion du cycle
court de la forêt y sont complètement
dingue la forêt c'est du cycle long
c'est c'est du carbone qui est contenu
dans les arbres mais ils ont rendu les
gens tellement il est long tellement
persécutés tellement serrer le kiki
tellement pas renouveler les postes
maintenant ils suicide il ya beaucoup de
suicides parmi les gens de 2 faut bien
comprendre que le gars ou une fille qui
vit dans la forêt il vit pas comme vous
et moi moi je suis un frénétique
j'arrête pas de magie tgb j'ai bien le
monde ne descend bon et pour arriver à
me calmer il faut que je sois en
vacances et que je leur mette à vivre
normalement mais celui qui vit au vite
toujours au rythme du matériau qu'on
travaille les gens qui font de la
politique qui vivent pratiquement
maintenant au rythme de la formation
continue et moi j'ai trouvé la parade je
regarde plus la télé b ont bien ça le
gao la fille qui vit dans la forêt il
vit au rythme de la chose dont il
s'occupe il s'occupe de la forêt de ce
qu'ils voient de ski sens de ce qu'il
entend faut revenir faut rester faut
attendre pour être bien sûr que
ça peut pas se passer autrement c'est
pas la peine de courir partout ça sert à
rien donc il faut être comme ça et vous
venez vous sautez sur les genres dire là
maintenant on va les faire si elle était
là on va rentabiliser tous alors les
gens il suffoquait c'est comme si vous
disiez à quelqu'un qui s'occupe de
nourrissons à l'aller faut emballer tout
ça a c'est à dire le jour dans deux
jours tu sens mais c'est ce qui se passe
dans plus on est devenus fous donc voilà
c'est ça que je veux arrêter les
matières premières je reviens dessus je
tu m'as tout faire donc on les prendra
on les achètera ceux qui les ont qu'est
ce que voulait faire enfin ça c'est
nettement puis le mieux c'est d'essayer
de s'en passer le plus possible de
trouver d'inventer de chercher de
combinés de fabriquer de produire de lui
ravir quoi bon mais en attendant faut
pas raconter l'histoire on va devoir
acheter aux uns aux autres et nous on va
leur faudra sont deux des choses on
parle un peu géopolitique ouais parce
qu'il faut que je m'en aille non non
mais sérieusement m'attend là mais il ça
fait
quatre minutes une heure 33 minutes il
est 20h30 4g doit une demi heure pas
plus s'il vous plaît me venant de
contrôler leur vous à ma place parce que
j'ai pas demande maintenant prêtre je
prends jamais un traître non je vois mes
bons donc alors s'il vous plaît flo qu
après apprend sa communauté la
communauté véhicules et je reviendrai
géopolitique ils sont nos alliés
on fonctionne dans l'ordre mais lien
c'est à dire les gens de 130 kg font
écouter les gens de 60 kg
puis son fort pluie imposent leur vision
des choses ok
quelles sont nos ali quelles sont nos
partenaires
qui à qui on peut faire confiance à qui
on peut pas faire confiance
alors
d'abord commençons par pardon ne peut
pas passer à côté
l'ordre du monde il change à intervalles
réguliers il est toujours pyramidale
car un chef des fois il y en a deux fois
c était la guerre froide
des fois on a pu alors tout le monde a
envie d'être chef et c'est la grosse
pagaille mais l'ordre et construit
jusque-là été construit sur les nations
ça reste la vérité et puis vous avez des
normes monopole on les a vu apparaître
des fois se rétracter puis réapparaître
mais maintenant ils sont arrivés à un
point de capacité de contrôle je ne dis
pas qu'il soit arrivé mais les gars ça
c'est plus qu'un monopole du passé
surtout quand vous en avez qui commence
à dire et en plus on va battre monnaie
là ça change tout extra terrien
extraterritorialité du droit ils ont
passé des maisons et il n'y a pas de
contrôle dans le moment donc là on a un
problème bien spécifique mais pour le
reste l'ordre est international il a été
on a eu deux patrons les russes et les
et les américains le système soviétique
s'est effondré il nous est restée les
américains qu'on dit ben nous on va
construire un nouvel ordre du monde
d'aller voir ce que vous allez voir et
d'ailleurs on commence en irak nous a
été vendu comme ça par monsieur bush
mais au moment où il faisait ça déjà il
y avait un doute sur leur puissance
réelle car vous l'avez dit le plus fort
commandes mais fort en quoi il faut être
très en armement énorme tadié il faut
montrer aux autres qu'on est capable de
détruire tout le monde et puis
deuxièmement il faut être capable
d'avoir une certaine autonomie
qui vous garantit votre richesse votre
prospérité et le rapport de force avec
les autres les etats-unis ne sont plus
là
ils ont en effet un énorme armement mais
ils vivent à crédit sur le reste du
monde et le reste du monde l'a compris
notamment ceux qui ont émergé j'y viens
dans un instant et ils sont déclinant et
à mon avis ils ont perdu la partie
pour plein de raisons démographiques
mais déjà dans leurs frontières d'accord
les états unis que vous avez sous les
yeux et là je serai pas là pour vérifier
le pari mais pas sûr que dans son temps
il faut encore là parce que la moitié du
territoire a été pris de force au
mexique que la population hispanophone
va devenir majoritaire et que si elle
est majoritaire à la main dans avec elle
une culture une grammaire une séance
d'une technique la poésie des lettres
une langue porte plus que un échange
et puis ils ne produisent plus rien en
tout cas pas échelle à laquelle il
faudrait qu'il le fasse quand vous
regardez
l'évaluation de la richesse des états
unis d'amérique chaque année
l'agriculture
l'industrie s'est essentiellement des
services le service et bienveillant faux
mais c'est pas ça qui est la production
de la richesse qu'elle le jour où se
coupe la chaîne d'approvisionnement peut
rester comme ça c'est ce qui nous arrive
en ce moment qu'elles sont deux ailiers
si on peut leur faire confiance pour
l'instant et virgile hier mais il
fallait d'abord rappelé le contexte
c'est vous qui mettez la pression pour
partir ouais j'aime être là parce qu'on
sent une puissance a émergé
qui en réalité était déjà le premier pib
du monde au 19e siècle c'est la chine
la chine qui a une vision du monde elle
même et des autres qui ont beaucoup
d'occidentaux n'arrive pas à comprendre
n'arrive pas à comprendre que les
chinois d'une manière générale s'appelle
pas l' empire du milieu pour rien ils
pensent qu'ils sont au milieu et que les
autres sont la périphérie et qu'est-ce
que les joues dix mois la population
française c'est moi qui la population du
canton de shanghai bon bah on peut
comprendre qui se représentent les
choses différemment un peu comme nous
quand on regarde le liechtenstein un
pardon pour le liechtenstein mais bon
voilà
l'ordre de grandeur moi je me rappelle
de discussion avec la ministre de
l'éducation chinoise elle était ministre
de mon truc là avec mes douze millions
d'élèves faisait le malin en face des
luxembourgeois mais bon elle avait 200
millions d'élèves à la maternelle donc
c'était un autre problème que lien donc
ils ont une vision du monde
et l'occident est extrêmement arrogant
les nations européennes qui sont les
nations en réalité violente je me sens
du trésor gobain
la force vu ce qu'on leur a fait subir
avant qui m'aime ils sont contents d'eux
mêmes comme souvent les gens qui
deviennent de plus en plus puissants et
ça les conduire à faire des erreurs s'il
n'y réfléchis pas à deux fois mais
restons sur l'ordre du monde il est
déséquilibré nous vivons avec un empire
finissants et avec un empire à part les
deux nous pose un problème de nature
différente mais un problème le premier
de ces problèmes c'est qu'on veut pas de
m moi j'en veux pas bon ça va m'amener à
votre question qui on a comme alliés
comme on fait nous ne voulons pas de m
alors on fait ce qu'on peut pour essayer
de se faufiler au milieu des plus
importants que nous mais on est là déjà
fait la preuve qu'on savait pas c'est de
bien des gens pour faire bien des choses
importantes on veut pas de m donc pour
l'instant celui qui prétend nous donner
des ordres en matière politique c'est
les états unis d'amérique en ce moment
là d'ordre ou les suisses ont ils ont
même plus besoin vous avez raison ils
ont leurs larbins ils sont formés dambre
les gens n'arrivent même pas imaginer
qu'on puisse faire autant regarder en ce
moment ils devraient tous et sert donc
les etats-unis se réunissaient poutine
pour discuter de la sécurité européen
venir c'est magnifique c'est vous
attendez là tout à l'heure au café vous
aurez le droit de rentrer je n'entre pas
dans la chambre c'est sain
où
elle a tous embarqués dans une guerre
qu'on nous annonce en ukraine qui est
une gesticulation général entre les uns
et les autres les uns en américain pour
pouvoir [__] l'otan là dedans
les russes pour montrer aux américains
qui sait ce qu'on va faire avec cette
fois ci est une ligne rouge non mais là
dedans on est capable de faire preuve
d'intelligence et de comprendre la part
de simagrées 1
mais on est aussi capable de comprendre
ça peut très mal tourner si quelqu'un
perd son sang froid s'il y en a un qui
fait l'imbécile puisque deux mesures
qu'est ce qui se passe il ya 6000 ogives
nucléaires en russie il y en a six mille
aux états unis d'amérique être qu'à
détruire 17 fois la planète est 16 fois
de trop un bon donc ils ont tout ça
alors
et puis alors on s'interroge sur le sens
de la politique est pratiqué par les
états unis moi j'ai une version qui est
un peu un peu triste mais très social je
pense que les bureaucrates
des agences de sécurité nord américaine
certains sont anti soviétique parce
qu'il parle russe qu'ils ont toujours
été anti soviétique alors maintenant il
se mentir us est bon ils n'ont pas trop
envie
qu'eux d'abord ils veulent utiliser leur
métier puis n'ont pas trop envie que les
rues s'entendre avec les européens parce
que là ça va commencer à faire quelque
chose de plus qu'il n'avait pas prévu
c'est réussi je peux pas prétendre je
suis allé trois fois là bas
on combien de temps ou très peu de temps
c'est à rien qui vaille la peine que je
je je me rends gorge de ça mais je ne
vais jamais pleuré avec un russe
pleurer l'expression des russes c'est
plus raide ans que gilles et
non c'est pas trop mon truc et à pleurer
sauf certaines circonstances mais je
sais de quoi il s'agit à propos des
russes la manière de voir le monde
il faut beaucoup s'intéresser à la
culture d'un peuple sa culture
historique qu'en france qu'on pense que
l'histoire c'est une rigolade dans bay
sont tous pleins d'histoires en france
aussi mais eux par exemple les européens
ne se rendent pas compte que ils ont eu
20 millions nord dans la guerre contre
les nazis et que c'est quelque chose de
très fort il n'y a pas de familles où il
n'y a pas eu quelqu'un qui est un héros
de la lutte 1 nos grands pères bon donc
c'est très très fort très très forme
alors
comment on fait
on veut pas se laisser embarquer dans
des guerres qui sont pas les nôtres avec
les américains comptent les russes pour
normal pour nous
ni avec les américains comptent les
chinois alors là sont encore plus dingue
parce que ce monde pour qu'on ferait un
truc pareil
quant aux chinois est un régime
politique qui ne plaît pas bah oui c'est
pas les seuls les saoudiens aussi en
régime qui nous plaît pas et plein
d'autres ont des régimes qui nous
plaisent pas sur l'épaule comme ça peut
pas être le way mais non mais bon ça
c'est des trucs il faut il faut arriver
à faire entendre ce que nous on croit
apportant les valeurs auxquelles on
croit contre les tyrannies quelle
qu'elle soit
mais il faut le faire dans des
conditions d'efficacité je vous coûte
hockey lih ouigours
la la qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec les
ouigours la france a dit mme lafrance
nos élus pour la majeure partie ont dit
c'est un génocide on est d'accord la
france insoumise s'est abstenu si j'ai
bien compris
pourquoi
parce que
un petit résumé un petit résumé de ce
qui se passe c'est que les ouïghours et
les chinois je vous écoute
il ya un problème
comme souvent dans les pays qui sont
composites c'est le cas de la chine il
ya toujours de la difficulté à articuler
les minorités avec la majorité ça c'est
la règle pour tout le monde ça vaut pour
nous aussi
et là-bas bon
il y a une tradition du centralisme qui
est plus que millénaire et puis
deuxièmement il ya un régime qui
présentent parfois des qualités il est
capable de
d'organiser méthodiquement les choses
et puis ça se transforme en son
contraire
quand il s'agit de liberté
clairement on ne peut pas se reconnaître
dans
leur façon de
traiter ces questions de liberté alors
avec les ouïghours ils ont hésité entre
plusieurs tactiques
dans un premier temps ils se sont dit
bon on fait comme pour les autres on les
intègre dans les structures du parti
communiste de l'assemblée nationale tout
ça et puis ça s'est pas passé comme
prévu c'est à dire qu'ils espéraient
qu'à la sortie de ça il aurait plus
d'histoire en gros 1 et puis c'est pas
ce qui s'est passé
il ya eu parmi les ouigours un regain de
l'adhésion à la religion islam est
évidemment que dans cet islam il y a eu
des gens qui sont passés aux méthodes
qu'on a pu voir s'appliquer ailleurs le
djihadisme il ya eu des attentats et à
partir de là la machine qui s'est mise
en route a été d'une brutalité absolue
et a conduit à une pratique d'une
violence dont il me semble qu'ils ne se
rendent même pas compte eux mêmes ont
détaillé pardon en détail comme comment
le rouleau compresseur chinois huawei
comment comment il sait kurd a par
exemple ils reconnaissent eux mêmes
qu'ils ont mis déjà en camp de travail
pour les rééduquer bon après tout
d'accord avec un truc pareil il ya un
million de gens nous dit-on là dedans
donc on sait tous que ça veut dire on
reconnaît la brutalité en chaîne que ça
peut donner alors cette utilisation des
fins non mais on peut pas être d'accord
avec sa réalisation des femmes de sa vie
anti ce monde culturel oui oui si vous
voulez enfin si ça oui c'est ça a lieu
on peut que condamner tout ça hein je ne
cherche pas à dire
alors si ça lui ça tombe bien on est
l'ambassadeur chinois a pas très
longtemps attendez attendez il nous a
dit oui mais c'est la presse occidentale
qui raconte ça c'est pas comme ça c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe là bas je
suis dit mais très bien vous allez me
faire visa open bar il nous va se
balader mode réplique et banon ils
veulent pas nous faire un visa voilà
donc ils s'en prennent à eux même si les
gens suite raconté ce qui leur plaît
sans veulent pas nous faire bien viser
open par c'est parce que c'est leur
politique intérieure et ça ne nous
regarde pas mais comment on fait pour
parler que des gens comme ça d'abord on
parle mais déjà non mais et ensuite on
vit pas n'importe quoi parce qu'il ya
une série de gens si vous voulez moi je
me positionne comme quelqu'un qui se
prépare à assumer une responsabilité de
pouvoir à portante et je demande à mes
amis de se comporter comme çà
condamné ou ne pas être d'accord ne pas
être d'accord condamné jouer la
hiérarchie quelque chose ça doit être
fait avec des mots qui vous permettent
d'intervenir sinon c'est irresponsable
par exemple dire il ya un génocide
l'or qui a toute une série de gens qui
disent
d'associations human rights watch et
plus pas combien d'autres de sinologue
qui disent écoutez employé par un mot
pareil parce que c'est vrai que ce
qu'ils font mais insupportable pour nous
tous et que si on continue dans cette
tente à la fin il va falloir démolir
tous ceux qui sont pas d'accord mais
utiliser un mot pareil je crois que ceux
qui ont décidé de voter ça hier sont des
hypocrites pourquoi parce que les
socialistes est ce que un seul jour ils
ont décidé d'arrêter les relations avec
pékin avec avec les chinois et jamais
ils l'ont fait avant et il continue
maintenant et même les responsables que
nous avons vu hier à l'assemblée
continue à entretenir à travers par
exemple la mairie de paris des relations
continuelle avec la chine donc à quoi ça
sert d'aller gesticuler en prononçant
des mots si vous voulez que quelqu'un
dans une manif biais à bâle génocide je
le comprends parfaitement que quelqu'un
qui a des liens personnels affectif
familiaux ou simplement de sympathie 10
c'est horrible tanger le site je le
comprends mais quand vous êtes dans la
sphère politique s'il est un génocide
alors on intervient pour l'arrêter que
vont militairement
comment on a fait jusque-là en serbie
c'est bien ce qu'on a fait quand on nous
a dit je saisis ta chance et s'est massé
rire parce que le la ratiocination entre
gens qui prendront des mots sans mesurer
les conséquences a alors qu'ils aient
envie d'aller cas quand il ya eu le
génocide au rwanda on est intervenu il
ya eu l'onu on peut discuter tout ce qui
s'est fait on peut tout discuter mais
c'est ça la réponse qu'on a fait on a
pas dire on va voter à l'assemblée
nationale un texte et ensuite on rentre
à la maison pour faire la partie de
canasta d'accord non mais bon faut être
sérieux avec les mots qu'on emploie si
on veut gouverner si on prétend
gouverner on ne dit pas n'importe quoi
pour se faire alors il faut voir avec
qui on dit n'importe quoi
comment le ps fait-il pour faire adopter
une motion dans laquelle il dit que
c'est un génocide avec la lrm parti au
pouvoir qui lui ne fait strictement rien
et qui dit d'ailleurs à ovation il n'est
pas question qu'on fasse quelque chose
alors si vous voulez rien faire pour
qu'on vous fait ça juste parce que de
manière politicienne
vous voulez dire à ben nous nous sommes
dans la compassion et nous sommes prêt à
dire n'importe quoi donc la question qui
se pose à nous français c'est comment à
la place qui est la nôtre nous avons la
capacité de dire aux chinois écoutez
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire nous
ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça vous nous
mettez dans une situation insupportable
parce que nous voulons avoir des bonnes
relations avec vous mais si vous
procédez à des méthodes pareilles on
comprend que c'est vos affaires
intérieures on comprend mais entendent
et nous nous parce que nous donner vos
clients on vous achète toutes sortes de
choses parce que nous on et vos amis on
vous méprise pas donc et c'est ça le
dialogue qu'il faut avoir c'est con
alors maintenant aussi un peu un peu
balayons devant notre porte pourquoi ils
font ça parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils vont
se débarrasser des djihadistes de cette
manière là voilà ce qu'ils pensent
alors exactement eh bien nous ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que toutes les
politiques de grossières répression de
des musulmans et de l'islam en général
au long de la poignée de frappadingue
qui font des attentats terroristes
débouche toujours sur le même le même
échec c'est à dire que vous donnez aux
extrémistes la représentation politique
qu'ils veulent avoir du grand nombre ne
permettait pas que les djihadistes
deviennent les représentants politiques
des ouïghours musulmans qui n'ont pas
plus envie de faire sauter des bombes
que la mouette que la plupart des gens
qu'on connaît et aujourd'hui dans le
monde partout la réplique qui est fait
contre le djihadisme cette tape et les
musulmans et moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ça je le dire en france et je le
dis de la même manière avec la même
franchise aux chinois je ne suis pas
d'accord cette politique ne mène nulle
part sinon qu'à diviser les gens à créer
de la haine et à donner la
représentation politique aux djihadistes
c'est une erreur totale dans bout à
l'autre le dire comme je suis en train
de le dire
voyez vous je sais que je prends arrive
pas ce qu'on me dit alors tu ne veux pas
condamné mais si je condamne et ya bien
sûr des politiciens qui sont là pour
dire à wimille est pas clair il est
ambigu je suis très claire par contre
ceux qui s'affrontent am aujourd'hui
c'est eux qui sont pas claires dans
leurs relations aux états unis
d'amérique parce que s'il avait le
courage de leurs attitudes politiques la
rm qui a été votée ça à l'assemblée
nationale ils iraient voir les chinois
aient leur dire écoute je viens de dire
écoute on peut pas être d'accord avec
cela qu'est ce que vous nous répondez
que c'est vos affaires intérieures on le
comprend mais vous entendez pas ce qu'on
vous dit vous intéressez pas bien sûr
que si les chinois écoute mais si vous
leur dites vous à vous faire signer ça
comme font les américains qui commencent
à essayer de leur serrer la gorge
la chine est à vous aider oui j'ai dit
bien leur serré la gorge l'alliance
qu'ils ont fait une nouvelle zélande
australie etats unis d'amérique grande
bretagne en fuite en dehors les français
qui étaient des bons petits caniches
pourtant qui avait participé aux
précédentes opérations navales dans le
cadre de l'otan à akwa est pourquoi
c'est faire tout ça pour créer un
rapport de forces militaires avec la
chine absurdité tout ça ne nous mène
nulle part par contre une politique
capable d'intervention quand un pays
surtout un pays très puissant
refuse-t-il de parler ça n'existe pas
donc ce n'est pas la bonne méthode de
jeter des déclarations qui ne font
qu'une chose montrer qu'on n'y croit pas
soi même parce que dire qu'on vote que
c'est un génocide est rentré à la maison
c'est la preuve qu'on croit pas soi-même
à ce qu'on raconte et je le dis à tous
ceux que cette histoire passionne comme
c'est mon cas parce que moi je veux être
lente constructeurs de paix vous m'avez
dit quelles sont nos alliés
nos alliés c'est la force des idées
nous sommes capables d'être indépendant
quiconque nous touche à un cheveu sera
détruit c'est pour ça qu'on a une
dissuasion nucléaire la notice fusion
nucléaire elle vous elle vous pousse zew
demain alors attendre on va passer à ça
parce que vous vous dites ça passait à
ça il est sa vraie mère 52 alors sois
belge d'hermine
prochaine réunion et on reste ensemble à
discuter ne peut pas appeler ça un bon
alors je réponds à la question suivante
en pin on est continuellement je
commence par je sais où j'en étais de
vous démontrer qu'elles peuvent être
quel peut-être nos stratégies alors
d'abord être souverain et être capable
de se défendre nous sommes dit la
dissuasion nucléaire ne vaut rien
j'accepte l'idée que ça vaut la peine
qu'on en parle je vais pas dire que je
suis d'accord avec vous mais je veux pas
dire non plus que ce que vous dites n'a
pas de sens parce que ça a du sens et
s'il faut faire tout de suite la
parenthèse on va la faire mais je
termine sur comment on peut être au
milieu des nations que fait la france a
elle doit être non alignés
non alignés
avec les américains ni avec les russes
mais avec les chinois et
encore un autre sujet mais aligné sur le
rap aussi non mais à venir 5e à 1 minute
56 kw à 10 alors la réponse est non
parce que ça n'a pas de sens qu'est ce
que tu veux faire avec 29 pays compass 2
idée commune sur la politique étrangère
alors on peut passer des heures à
bavarder ça oui on a d'ailleurs payé des
gens pour ça on a nommé une femme ou un
jésus qui sait maintenant depuis c'est
le tour des ministres commissaire aux
affaires étrangères on lui dit mais
madame c'était la première c'est la
baronne ashton ont lieu mais vous savez
à quoi vous parce qu'il n'y a pas de
politique étrangère elle a dit cette
chose incroyable pour une libérale c'est
une c'est une ps donc c'est une libérale
est le diable pour une fois c'est
l'organe qui va créer la fonction alors
nous les français comme d'habitude on a
leash qu'est ce qu'on fait on envoie le
meilleur des nôtres là-bas pour
organiser le service ils sont pas ils
sont pas contenues au prix il a organisé
leur truc ils sont 5000 on ne sait pas
quoi faire 1 et nouveau bond s'est
dépouillée on a vendu les locaux de nos
ambassades parce qu'on peut le faire
puis à l'europe on a réduit maintenant
on en est le président de la république
a décidé que après avoir déjà supprimé
30 % des postes et bien les ambassadeurs
sont plus des ambassadeurs ses
administrateurs d'état exit la fonction
spécialisés de diplomates d'accord voilà
le deuxième réseau diplomatique du monde
détruit de l'intérieur parce qu'ils
doivent qui devait le conduire alors ne
parlez pas de la politique étrangère de
l'europe il y en à port et la défense
européenne c'est pas demain que vous la
verrez parce que tout ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire c'est de faire les
gentils wagon des états unis d'amérique
et de l'otan et nous ici on nous raconte
des histoires on se raconte toujours des
histoires en france le couple franco
allemand
il ya de la libido du roman et tout ça
n'existe pas les allemands eux mêmes
sont les premiers à dire s'appelle un
moteur connaissent mais les moteurs que
le couple apparemment et eux ils croient
que c'est un moteur point final et c'est
que des histoires comme ça on sera
content qu'il va y avoir une défense
européenne parce que nous français
depuis de gaulle on a pris l'habitude
d'une défense indépendante mais les
autres qui savent même pas que ça existe
j'avais vu les polonais ils sont passés
du pacte de varsovie à l'otan ils
étaient fanatiques du pacte est
maintenant fanatiques de tant qu est ce
qu on fait que des gens pareils alors
ils font ce qu'ils veulent je veux pas
leur dire du mal mais moi je ferais
autrement je ne fera pas comme ça nous
défendons
deux dans le monde notre puissance elle
est ni militaire ni même économique la
puissance de la france et ce qu'elle
représente
un concept abstrait liberté égalité
fraternité donc nous aurons une
politique un non-alignés 2
altermondialiste que dirons-nous aux
gens écoutez un peu désarmée quoi
comment ben oui quand c'était l'union
soviétique comme on parlait de désarmer
maintenant on parle plus là pour la
première fois les chinois ont fait suer
tout le monde sait pas combien de temps
ils ont fait une déclaration des cinq en
dix ans une guerre nucléaire ne peut pas
être gagnée
tout le monde s'en fout car cela fait
attention pourquoi ils disent
non mais pourquoi il dit ça
parce qu'il voit bien qu'ils sont en
train de faire monter les tensions et
que le premier qui perd son sang froid
et tout va sauter donc ils disent lire
nucléaire peut pas être gagnée bas en
effet don ching guerre nucléaire ne peut
être gagnée alors on pourrait peut-être
commencé à remballer le matériel je
propose que la france participe au
traité pour l'interdiction des armes
nucléaires en observateur nous avons
nous mêmes des armes nous sommes
d'accord pour désarmer et parce qu'on a
le plus un et puis on désarmera quand on
arrivera nous nous on à 280 ogives ils
en ont six mille voile commence par nous
fera aussi un effort on va le faire
d'autant plus facilement pour la raison
que je vais vous expliquer mais je
termine sur l'alter mondialisme ça veut
dire que nous les français on va épauler
par exemple les boliviens qui demande
que ont créé un tribunal climatique
international comme il ya un tribunal
pénal international nous allons nous a
animé une action politique
internationale pour qu' il y à un traité
de non prolifération des énergies
carbonées voilà comment la france va
être respectée parce qu'elle sera
respectable on n'ira pas vous les
français vous connais vous arrivez vous
raconter des grands trucs sur la
république la liberté et tout le reste
et après vous nous vendre des armes pour
aller casser la figure du voisin de la
côte est donc moi je crois à la
puissance française de cette manière là
la dernière fois qu'on a été en guerre
contre tout le monde c'est à dire après
la guerre la grande révolution je parle
pour décider à la fois qu'on était en
guerre contre tout le monde on était mal
c'était la deuxième guerre mondiale
d'accord et qui nous a tiré d'affaires
ceux qui résistaient et russe mais ici
l'honneur qui c'était un bon alors ça
c'est pour la diplomatie
altermondialiste moi je crois ça à la
force de la france comme ça en plus en
mettant en partage allez hop au lieu de
dire des bonnes phrases à l'afrique
comme chez monsieur macron après avoir
demandé un président de la république au
burkina s'ils allaient réparer la la
clim un haut lieu de faire des discours
en général j'irai des choses concrètes
de fait voler le 19e siècle à cause de
l' esclavage vous êtes fait voler du
xxème siècle à cause de la colonisation
je vous propose quelque chose parce qu'à
nous tous seuls on n'y suffira pas
faisons une université francophone de
l'espace des métiers de l'espace ont
partagé avec vous faisons une université
francophone des métiers de la mer on
partage vous verrez si on sera pas une
grande puissance beaucoup plus qu'à
faire les marioles derrière les
américains alors notre dissuasion
maintenant venons ici alors je n'ai je
prends pas en traître il est 20 heures
59 ça fait une heure 59 qu'on discute
bon on arrête dans un quart d'heure le
temps qu'il me faut pour la dissuasion
d'accord donc si ça leur demande pardon
à ceux qui nous écoutent qu'il en reste
quelques-uns faut passer un point il
reste combien
on est seize mille j'aime bien la haye
c'est pas mal il va falloir prendre un
deal avec la communauté de revenir pour
deux raisons 1 vous nous avez plantés il
ya deux mois ni pour les faire six
minutes chez tf1
ça fait marrer mais ça ne fait pas mal
mais moi non plus parce que j'ai dit
comment ça se fait que kim carr vieux
plus de moi mais quoi abbassi club un
mois depuis la 1ère fois que j'étais
venu ici j'étais enchanté bon allez on
avance parce que donc on prend un deal
avec la communauté il va falloir revenir
pour parler plus de géopolitique promis
promis promis d'accord j'accepte non
mais promis et avoir la présidentielle
si avant la guerre si d'anciens oui je
regarde
on finit sur l'a10 fallait que je
m'intéresse de parler de ça je suis trop
content de pouvoir en parler on n'en
parle jamais on peut jamais en parler
nulle part et a qu'ici que j'ai pu avoir
le temps de m'exprimer il ya deux ans et
là comme je suis en train de le faire
sans être interrompu toutes les deux
secondes comme dit d'aller plus vite et
je sais pas quoi c'est moi qui n'y plus
vite pour une fois
la dissuasion on en reparle on n'en
parle pas on continue on continue pas où
passer à un autre sujet je voudrais
qu'on parle de la primaire populaire on
en parle maintenant on en parle après
bernie sanders la primaire populaire et
ça affronter la fronde et la première
populaire le mec au chili il est passé
avec 56 % face à un asile y passer par
la primaire populaire mais en mon nom
franchement attend on va parler de
sujets sérieux on s'en fout de la
primaire populaire non le sujet et 300
mille ha oui moi aussi pas d'accord
alors moi il y en a autant qui ont
parrainé ma candidature donc la
discussion est close je vois pas
l'intérêt que ça apporte à la question
car est bonjour monsieur mélenchon quels
sont selon lui le meilleur argumentaire
pour amener les abstentionnistes sur le
chemin de la citoyenneté
ils n'ont jamais cessé d'y être ils sont
citoyens comme nous tous ils ont décidé
que ça valait plus la peine parce qu'on
se foutait deux parce que en 2005 ils
ont voté non on a dit on a très bien
compris c'est oui parce qu'ensuite ils
ont élu un socialiste qui leur a dit mon
ennemi c'est la finance et ensuite il
s'est mis entièrement au service de la
finance ensuite ils ont élu un jeune
homme qui leur disait avec moi ça va
être la révolution tout le monde va être
libre vous allez pouvoir exprimer votre
créativité du pipeau bon donc faut
comprendre que derrière les gens des
raisons de ne plus avoir confiance et
puis deuxièmement la manière de ramener
tout le monde grands combats c'est
d'avoir un objet au combat moi je me
rappelle je me retrouve à mon âge en
train de redescendre un mot d'ordre que
je défends des comme j'avais 20 ans qui
était la retraite à 60 ans et les gens
disaient on n'y arrivera pas mais c'est
bien vous en occuper et on l'a fait bon
mais je veux venir pardon excusez moi
d'y revenir au moins pour que cette
question de géopolitique qui est la
question la dissuasion je vous supplie
de comprendre que c'est une question
très importante
si vous n'êtes pas défendu vous dépendez
des autres vous pouvez trouver ça très
bien pas moi aujourd'hui un doute la
dissuasion des français vous avez
compris le concept de dissuasion c'est
c'est une touche de castes ou alors
virgule faut d'abord qui me touchent
donc une défense posthume en france un
cours but on n'est plus là un coup au
but sur la centrale de nogent un coup au
but dans la vallée du rhône terminée il
ya plus de france
donc c'est gravissime toute notre
affaire repose sur la dissuasion si vous
êtes sûr que je casse tout vous dire est
bon peut-être que ça peut attendre de
leur taper dessus grâce à ça on est en
paix pour que ça marche pour que l'outil
puisse pas être anticipé vecteur un
vecteur
on avait des fusées mise au plateau
d'albion les arv et parce que bon quand
même là c'était trop simple on a
maintenant des avions et des sous marins
d'un câble sous marin et une flottille
d'avions qui peut porter la bombe jeudi
rien des avions qui porte la bombe je me
concentre pour l'instant sous les
sous-marins qui l arme la plus
perfectionnée que nous avons dans ce
domaine qui est pas facile à intercepter
je ne dis pas que c'est facile
d'intercepter un avion français mais
tout le monde comprend que c'est plus
facile d'intercepter un avion plus
d'intercepter un sous-marin aussi
longtemps que 1 on le voit pas 2 on
n'attend pas si on le voit depuis
l'espace ou si on l'entend parce qu'il
ya des câbles et que on l'entend 2x
manière tout ça ne sert plus à rien
c'est à dire que vous êtes en train
d'acheter des arbalètes à l'époque du
fusil alors c'est sympa vous pouvoir les
meilleurs arbalète du monde mais ça sert
à rien là on est on peut être dans cette
situation c'est pour ça que je veux
qu'on en parle je ne suis pas en train
de dire ça ne marche plus je vous dis
juste ne me prenez pas pour quelqu'un
qui n'est pas capable de comprendre que
quelque chose a changé comment je le
sais comment que rien n'est même pas les
coréens s'il est encore un le lit
simicek hypersonique ils font un star
fait un stage ils font ils tirent à la
verticale ils crament tous les
satellites au retour tous âges de tous
et tout le monde l'a fait et ça vole à
plusieurs on sait même plus d'où il
arrive mais attends tu vas voir oui et
non c'est pas l'objet hypersonique c'est
le tir depuis la terre sur le satellite
ça revient au même admettons mais les
nord coréens nous ont pas là encore sur
la non ils sont ils sont capables de
faire un stage je prime de raser
l'intégralité de tous les satellites qui
sont autour de nous et en plus
maintenant avec un missile ni personne
parler foot et pas la trouille à tout le
monde c'est pas tout les truies jamais
d'accord écoutez en vérité nous on n'a
pas cette technologie là on
quitte pas capable de faire la même
chose que les nord-coréens on n'a même
pas les torpilles à la hauteur des
chinois à la hauteur des américains à la
hauteur des rues sont d'accord pour
parler dans leur dos traditionnels ils
disent non et puis après écoute et je
n'en sais rien parce que sera ma vie
mais j'ai pas envie de me la rendre plus
compliquée dans 80 jours si c'est moi
qui suis élu en arrivant en diable ce
type a dit clooney baup il avait aucun
moyen de se défendre
mais non mais arrêtez avec ça à la
désespérance permanente non c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai les français sont
capables de tirer sur n'importe quel
satellite de n'importe qui qu'est ce que
vous racontez on est capable d'arriver à
voir sur terre des surfaces qui sont
moins grandes que 50 cm alors arrêtez de
vous prendre la tête et on est le
troisième port spatial mondiale c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est de dire le
sujet est le suivant si tel et tel pays
sont capables de tirer depuis la terre
sur les satellites tout le monde
comprend même en mettant de côté la
question de ce qu'on est capable de
faire depuis l'espace sur l'espace d'un
satellite à un autre même en se laissant
de côté la question de savoir si dans
satellite on peut tirer sur la terre en
laissant toutes ces questions de côté en
regardant une seule depuis la terre
est-ce qu'on peut tirer dans l'espace et
qu'est ce que ça donne comme résultat le
résultat il est évident c'est que dix
minutes après vous avez plus
d'électricité vous avez plus de
communication des plus de ceci ou de
cela et on sait pas le nombre de choses
et j'ai pas envie de raconter des
horreurs mais clairement ça veut dire
que cette arme est une arme contre
laquelle vous ne pouvez quasiment rien
parce que moment où on voulait faire
quelque chose ça s'arrête et si en plus
mettons que le président vous savez bien
que ça se passe pas comme certains
croient c'est pas il ya pas un tiroir
vous avec un mouton pouf labeaume parent
c'est comme ça que ça se passe mais vous
avez une décision à prendre 1 vous savez
pas qui vous a frappé là ça change quand
même tout non surtout si vous avez
plusieurs ennemis je sais pas qui vous a
frappé par ce qui vous a envoyé un truc
hyper sonic ou parce que il a tiré de
l'espace ou bien parce que depuis la
terre il a détruit les quatre satellites
militaires que nous aurons bientôt qui
nous permet de capter l'activité
magnétique de tout le monde qui fait que
les français sont mieux renseigné que
n'importe quel européen sur tout le
monde entier on a tiré sa ya pas
longtemps en décembre avant le télescope
en bon donc faux c'est pour dire à quand
même les gens on sait faire et puis ce
n'est pas fait on fera parce que moi je
demande occuperait pas que ça soit fait
donc rien de savoir ça modifie notre
système de défense
donc moi je pense je pense mais je peux
être démentis et je sais que ça ne sera
pas en 24 heures je pense qu'il vaut
mieux transposer la dissuasion dans
l'espace
et si on la transpose dans l'espace
c'est à dire que tout le monde comprend
bien que le premier qui chargent pouya
des français prend gros gros gros
risques parce que nous sommes capables
depuis l'espace de taper les autres
satellites et parce que depuis la terre
nous sommes capables de taper les plus
importants transposer la dissuasion dans
l'espace elle cesserait d'être nucléaire
elle deviendrait lié à tout ce qu'on
peut interrompre d'accord à ce moment là
vous avez la base d'une double
discussion
qui vous permet de dire pourquoi vous
gardé des bombes si ça sert à rien nous
vous pouvez reprendre la discussion sur
la dissuasion nucléaire sur des bases
réalistes c'est à dire que celui qui
vient qui vous dit pas besoin de ça pour
me défendre le fait de partir vous avez
besoin aussi des arcs et des flèches
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de me
raconter donc on peut démonter puisqu'on
est dans l'espace et qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans l'espace
nous moi j'étais partisan qu'on en reste
au traité de 1967 démilitarisation de
l'espace
pas d'armes dans l'espace bon bah
puisque tout mounier tout le monde a
installé son bazar et c'est tellement
vrai en nous les français on bat tous
les records les américains crée un état
major de l'espace personnellement de
rien à personne
et puis nous leur président ils décident
de créer un état-major de l'espace ils
demandent rien à personne non plus donc
nous avons décidé de violer un traité
que nous avons signé on s'en fout et on
n'en parle pas une minute à l'assemblée
nationale j'ai déjà parlé quatre fois
cette histoire de dissuasion ou alou
personne répond un type de l1 l'om que
je salue quel président d'une commission
de la défense lui me répond en disant
bien mélenchon a raison de poser la
question puis après ça répond pas c'est
la tienne un il dit ah oui mais nous on
a les meilleures armes nucléaires du
monde et tout ça il ya du personnel
c'est pas le sujet c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c est ce que ça sert à quelque
chose ou pas moi je sais que à partir du
moment où on me dit prison tous
militarisé l'espace en violation du
traité précédent plus bas phù dông da
discutons des nouvelles conditions
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans l'espace mais
si on discute de ce qu'on fait dans
l'espace on pourrait commencer par
l'iace à la discussion sur le
désarmement nucléaire sur terre donc à
chaque fois il faut tirer d'une
situation le meilleur pour pouvoir
avancer mais pour ça faut être fort faut
être respectés pas seulement
militairement a donc on évite d'aller
s'embarquer dans des aventures dont on
ne sort pas comme celle dans laquelle on
s'est embarqué en afrique mais surtout
parce qu'on montre qu'on est de bonne
volonté et puis surtout qu'on est fort
qu'on est puissant donc les russes ont
tiré sur un satellite ont mis en mille
morceaux tout le monde a poussé des cris
de putois se disent hypocrite qui sont
en fait autant déjà 1 donc ce n'est pas
le sujet alors nous les français nous
devons faire la démonstration que nous
sommes capables pour que tout le monde
le comprenne bien que nous sommes
capables d'établir un pont monde avec ce
qui les objets qui sont dans l'espace
comme ça ça fait réfléchir tout le monde
deuxièmement on sort d'une l'état-major
intégré de l'otan de l'espace n'avons
rien à [__] là-dedans on se débrouille
tout seul pour pouvoir faire ça faut
sortir tous les matériels américains qui
sont dans notre matériel embarqué les
logiciels qui sont dans nos missiles les
logiciels qui sont au ministère de la
défense qui sont nord-américain tous on
y porte d'entrée d'accord et l'oncle sam
est installé chez nous avec sa serviette
et sont couverts bon tout ça termine et
on sort et il n'y a pas longtemps il ya
eu des manoeuvres j'excuse massy vous le
savez une manoeuvre commune naulleau
temps avec les américains et les
allemands qu'est ce que les allemands
bien tout là dedans ou me le dire bon
ils n'ont rien à faire là en tout cas
moi je fais pas de manoeuvre avec eux et
puis on pourrait terminer l'état-major
de l'espace de l'otan ou est-il
installés en france à toulouse là où on
a notre centre où nous collectons des
informations qui arrivent de l'espace
notamment par exemple la mission sur
mars 1 vous savez qu'il ya plein de
matériel français d'en bas au lieu de
pleurer tout le temps là la caméra qui
sort là elle est française le truc qui
s'est dit trou dans la terre ces
français donc on sait faire des tas de
choses donc vous reposer fille me dit
rousset bien eh ben on sait filmer des
troupes ont lancé ce cadre en trop et
puis on sait ce qu'il ya dans l'oeil de
la caméra à aller c'est bon on définit
alors donc il nous reste deux minutes
donc ça c'est la partie 1 parce qu'il a
toutes les questions intérieures qu'on a
pas pu la connerie n'a 25 sujets qu'on
n'a pas pu aborder mais je reviens un
peu à peu près comme vous voulez
d'accord mais mimi d'une pâte ferme il
promit drôle il promis non mais attends
promis je gêne cette émission je peux le
dire la preuve regardez ce que j'ai
l'air d'un type malheureux comme comme
je sors d'un plateau de 2 de la télé
publique ou de la radio publique non
on met à brut pas les livres pas les
conseils pour les générations ont
réservé à ça pour la deuxième partie sur
lesquels sujet y aura qu à un nombre de
ne pas les sujets d'accords mais il faut
qu'on parle du du hacking ces termes au
sujet jean luc mélenchon merci c'est moi
à vous tous merci pour votre terrible
patience j'aime écouter parler sans fin
comme ça
[Musique]
non